Hallo und herzlich Willkommen zum Chaos Radio 209 aus dem Chaos Computer Club Berlin in der Marienstraße 11, zu dem ihr, falls ihr euch jetzt zufällig, also jetzt euer neuartiges Rundfunk- umfangsgerät angegangen ist und euch fragt, was zur Hölle passiert da, auch vorbeikommen könnt. Wir senden heute live, wie gesagt, aus dem Club und es geht um Open Source-Finanzierung. Also darum, wie Software die Leute programmieren und dann deren Quellcode veröffentlichen. Ja, es gibt noch ein paar kleine Details, die wir vielleicht auch diskutieren werden, wie die da unter Umständen davon leben können. Und da begrüße ich jetzt recht herzlich im Chaosradio 219 zu Gast, den Herrn Danimo. Guten Tag. Ich bin Matthias Kirschner von der FSFE, auch Free Software Foundation Europe genannt. Hallo.
Guten Abend.
Das ist ja fast noch schlimmer als das Bundesministerium für Familie, Frauen, Senioren und Jugend.
Hier ist der Rettungsschirm, oder?
Den lasse.
Guten Abend.
Aus dem Club in Berlin und den Erdgeist. Hallo. So, und warum kommen wir gerade heute auf dieses Thema über Open-Source-Finanzierung zu sprechen? Das liegt daran, dass es gerade einen aktuellen Anlass gibt und das mögen wir Radiomacher ganz besonders. Und zwar ist es ja so, wenn man derzeit von E-Mail-Verschlüsselung spricht, dann meint man ja meistens GnuPG. Also es gibt andere Möglichkeiten, E-Mails zu verschlüsseln, aber keine, die man zumindest sozusagen in den Kreisen, denen ich verkehre oder über die ich lese, benutzt. Und ich werde dir gerade schon komisch angeguckt, es gibt bestimmt auch andere Sachen, aber GnuPG ist halt sozusagen so ein Standardding. Und dahinter steht tatsächlich auch ein Open-Source-Entwickler, oder genauer gesagt, eigentlich einer, so las es sich zumindest in Artikeln, und dem war das Geld ausgegangen. Und der hatte da, wie man das heutzutage macht, Crowdfunding gemacht. Das hat dann irgendwie nicht so richtig funktioniert. Und dann hat eine Zeitung einen Artikel geschrieben, wo es so hieß, Entschuldigung, dieser Typ braucht Geld. Und dann, dann ist es wirklich passiert, aber es musste halt erst dazu kommen, der, oh Gott, jetzt habe ich den Namen vergessen, super Vorbereitung, Herr Koch, Werner Koch. Der ist es ja, der steckt dahinter, ist tatsächlich ein Deutscher, was auch sozusagen überraschend ist, wenn man das nicht weiß. Der ist ja auch bei der FSFE, Matthias, sozusagen dein Kollege kann man so sagen. Der hat auch so auch Mitgründer gewesen.
Ja, der Werner hat damals die Free Software Foundation Europe 2001 mitgegründet gehabt.
War das denn jetzt sozusagen wirklich so dramatisch, wie sich das anhört, das Projekt kurz vor dem Ende, kein Geld mehr da oder war es eher so, naja gut, wenn das jetzt nicht klappt, dann müssen wir halt mal gucken.
Na ja, also, so Zeitungsartikel sind natürlich immer ein bisschen, die erzählen halt eine Geschichte und die Geschichte ist dann vielleicht auch ein bisschen überspitzt erklärt, aber es war schon so, dass Werner sehr lange Zeit GnuPG entwickelt hat und das auch jetzt mit einer Finanzierung, die eigentlich für so ein wichtiges Projekt ziemlich unter dem war, was man so gewohnt ist, also was auch die meisten Leute nicht erwartet hätten und noch so 2013 war Werner auch ziemlich demotiviert und hat irgendwie, ihm hat die Motivation da gefehlt, weiterzumachen und da viel Freizeit auch mit reinzustecken und nicht so viel rauszubekommen und zu wenig Geld zu haben, um sich jetzt einfach nicht jeden Tag Gedanken machen zu müssen, wie man die Familie so auch mit durchkriegt.
Und wir wollen halt genau das besprechen, also wie das gehen kann, weil GnuPG ist ja nicht die einzige Sache, sondern es ist ja generell so, das Internet funktioniert mit Software und diese Software ist relativ häufig Open Source und wird sozusagen relativ weit verbreitet genutzt, aber es fließt halt manchmal recht wenig Geld. Und wir wollen halt mal darüber reden, wie das passieren kann, wie es vielleicht schon passiert ist. Wir haben Danimo und Lasse hier, sagen beides Leute, die mit Open Source-Software leben oder von Open Source-Software auch ihre Brötchen verdienen und wollen auch darüber reden, was man vielleicht so von staatlicher und pädagogischer Seite da machen könnte, um das in Zukunft anders zu machen. Bevor wir mit dem anderen, mit dem aber alles anfangen, ist ja die spannende Frage eigentlich, was ist denn genau Softwareentwicklung, weil das da was finanziert werden muss, das bedeutet ja anscheinend, dass es relativ komplex ist, was da passiert. Und wenn man so Open Source-Software-Entwicklung hört, ja so Open Source, das sind doch die Programme, die da stellen, die stellen den Quellcode ins Internet. Das kann dann auch jeder sich kopieren, wenn er will. Und das hat immer so diesen Anruf oder das Klischee von, da ist halt so ein einziger verrückter Programmierer, der sagt, ich programmiere jetzt mal die Software und dann ist das schon alles super. Aber vielleicht steckt da ein bisschen mehr dahinter. Könnt ihr mal für die nicht Auskönner umreißen, was denn alles Teil einer Softwareentwicklung ist? Oder auch was alles passieren muss, damit so ein auch relativ komplexes System wie eine Verschlüsselungssoftware über Jahre am Leben erhalten wird? Das ist nicht da einer von euch finde?
Das gibt es auch, dass einfach nur ein einzelner verrückter Programmierer im Keller sitzt und so ein Projekt über Jahre lang pflegt. Ich habe selber zwei Softwareprojekte, die ich genauso pflege und die auch weit benutzt sind. Es kommt immer auf die Komplexität an. Es kommt darauf an, wie viel Dokumentation man nebenbei noch pflegen muss. Es kommt darauf an, ob man Internationalisierung möchte, also ob man will, dass das User Interface, wenn es eins gibt, was für mehr als nur Programmierer gedacht ist, auch für Menschen mit nicht englischsprachigem Hintergrund verstehbar ist.
Wie umfangreich die AP ist sicherlich. Je mehr AP, desto mehr muss ich testen, sicherstellen, dass es über alle Versionen hinaus funktioniert. Also AP im Sinne von, dass Programme mit anderen Programmen reden können.
Okay, aber das ist ja schon zu sagen, okay, der Aufwand steigt mit der Komplexität der Software, aber trotzdem noch mal diese einzelnen Schritte einer Software. Also was passiert denn da?
Software ist ja nur ein sehr weites Feld. Das ist sowohl ein Open Source als auch nicht Open Source. Das ist von einer einfachen Programmbibliothek bis zu einer Text- oder Tabellenverarbeitung. Das ist ja genau alles, was man da fassen kann. Und je nachdem, was diese Software am Ende leistet, muss die natürlich auch von einem Team von Leuten oder von einer einzelnen Person gepflegt werden. Also das ist natürlich kein Once-Has-Fits-All, weder in der Entwicklung von kommerziellen Programmen noch in Entwicklung von Open Source-Programmen realistisch.
Okay, was Marcus vielleicht meint, in einem eher kleineren Projekt, gerade so eine One-Man-Show oder drei, vier Leute, natürlich gehört die Homepage dazu, Dokumentation schreiben. Also um neben dem rein entwickelnden Software sind zig Sachen zu machen, wo die Techniker dann auch dazu tendieren zu sagen, ach, können wir auch selber machen, so eine kleine Homepage mal eben erstellen. Bisschen Text schreiben kann ja nicht so schwer sein. Das merkt man dann auch sehr oft in Software-Projekten, dass da keine Profis am Werk waren.
Das selbe geht für User-Interfaces von Programmen, wo es auch Profis da draußen gibt, die zunehmend auch Lust darauf haben, ein Open Source-Projekt mitzumachen. Das sind so UXler oder UI-Designer, die sich darauf spezialisiert haben, auch gerade komplexe Software, dem Anwender schön geschmackhaft zu machen. Sieht man zuletzt bei diversen Applikationen, dass das mal funktioniert.
Also du meinst, daher kam früher der Ausspruch, das sieht ja aus wie Open Source, weil das gar noch nicht funktioniert hat und das ändert sich jetzt langsam?
Ich kenne nur den Ausdruck, das sieht aus wie Industrie-Software.
Okay, ich trete trotzdem mal zurück. Also das alles, was ihr sagt, das sind ja Dinge, die kann man auch irgendwann fertig haben und so hört es sich zumindest an. Die Frage ist ja, wenn so eine Software erst mal gemacht wurde, was passiert denn dann hinterher noch? Also muss das, wie aufwendig ist eine Pflege dieser Software? Wie aufwendig ist es da, eine neue Versionsnummer zu programmieren und so weiter und so fort und das aktuell zu halten?
Also das hängt neben dem Umfang der Software, was Erdgeist gerade schon angesprochen hatte, auch wesentlich davon ab, wie viel Erfahrung derjenige, der sie entwickelt, mitbringt. Also wenn derjenige quasi ein Background hat und weiß, okay, ich muss mich um besagte Homepage kümmern, ich muss irgendwo meinen Quellcode so unterstellen, dass ich irgendwie nachvollziehen kann, was gemacht wurde. Also Versionierung etc. pp. das ist ja alles erst mal infrastrukturlich überhaupt erst mal brauche, bevor ich auch nur unter Umständen mit der ersten Zeile Code angefangen habe. Wenn man da ein bisschen Erfahrung hat bzw. wenn man sich zu helfen weiß, dadurch, dass man beispielsweise so fertige Dienste wie GitHub benutzt oder so etwas, dann geht das ganz gut, weil dann kann man auch so Veröffentlichungsprozesse sehr gut automatisieren. Das Erste, was ich mir mittlerweile angewohnt habe, ist, auf eine sehr hohe Automatisierung zu achten. Weil es ist ein Unterschied, ob ich auf einen Knopf drücken muss und da fällt eine Software raus, die ich vielleicht noch mal ein bisschen testen muss oder ob ich alle Schritte von Hand machen muss. Das ist auch so die Sache. Man sagt immer, Informatiker sind faul. Das hat aber nicht mal was damit zu tun, dass sie wirklich faul sind, sondern dass einfach der Aufwand ein bisschen händelbar sein muss. Und das ist eben genau der Unterschied. Release ich eine Software mit einem Aufwand von einer Stunde plus vielleicht irgendwie testen, ob das alles so Hand und Fuß hat oder verschwende ich einen Tag, um dieselben Befehle jedes Mal wieder auszuführen. Also das gehört halt auch noch so ein bisschen mit dazu.
Ich denke, es gibt noch eine andere Achse. Man erkennt bei einiger Software und bei einigen Projekten, dass der Programmierer die Programmiersprache während des Programmierens dieses Projekts erlernt hat.
Was ja auch ein legitimes Ziel sein kann.
Muss man aber eigentlich dann genauso markieren und das ist ja irgendwie eins meiner Lieblingsthemen, dass wie zum Glück meine Software von ganz früher ist dem gnädigen Gottes Bitrotts zum Opfer gefallen und da guckt keiner mehr drauf und es benutzt auch keiner ein Produktivsystem. Also eines der klassischen Argumente, wenn man so PHP-Software mal anguckt, ist so, dass viele Leute, die gerade am Programmieren sind, weil PHP eine Sprache ist, die ziemlich rewarding ist, man sieht schnell was in seinem Browser, dass dort ziemlich viele Leute dabei sind, die ihr erstes Open-Source-Projekt genau mit diesem PHP machen und viele Leute, die nach ähnlicher Funktionalität brauchen, wie was dieses Projekt gerade implementiert, nehmen es dann einfach ohne zu begreifen, in welchem technischen Level, welcher Expertise der Programmierer gerade ist und dann sieht man dann auch, dass dann die nächste Version plötzlich einmal komplett umgeschmissen ist, weil der Programmierer gerade ein neues Programmierparadigma gelernt oder verinnerlicht hat. Und dann muss man dann schon zwischen den Versionssprüngen mal schauen, wie radikal sich API und Implementierung geändert haben.
Aber das hört sich ja sozusagen eher nach einem Hobbyprojekt an.
Ja, so funktioniert das Internet. Was glaubst du, was Open-Source-Software zu wählen da draußen ist?
GnuPG ist ein Hobbyprojekt?
Das ist als Hobbyprojekt auch entstanden ursprünglich.
Also GnuPG ist als Hobbyprojekt mit gestartet, aber dann hat ja auch Werner Koch damals eine Firma mitgegründet und dann ist das ja als Firma mitgelaufen und die Entwicklung ist damit gemacht worden. Ich würde gerne kurz noch eine Anmerkung machen mit zu der Komplexität. Es ist natürlich auch nochmal ein Unterschied, entwickle ich eine Software alleine und habe ein Interesse in welche Richtung ich gehen möchte oder umso mehr Leute die Software verwenden, umso unterschiedlicher Interessen gibt es dann vielleicht auch, dass die die Software gerne in eine andere Richtung hätten. Gibt es andere Entwickler, die auch mitmachen und eigentlich was anderes machen wollen. Haben die zum Beispiel Kunden, die dafür bezahlen, dass man in die Richtung geht und jemand anderes, der ein Projekt mit entwickelt, der wird dafür bezahlt, dass das Projekt in die entgegengesetzte Richtung geht. Und das ist auf jeden Fall, was umso unterschiedlicher Interessen es bei der Entwicklung gibt, umso komplexer wird das Ganze und umso schwerer ist es, das zusammenzuhalten.
Moment mal, gerade waren wir noch zu sagen, was ist denn überhaupt Softwareentwicklung und jetzt sagst du schon, da bezahlen Leute. Jetzt ist ja Open Source Software grob zusammengefasst eine Software, deren Quellcode irgendwie frei im Netz verfügbar ist und meistens bedeutet das auch, dass die Software kostenlos weggegeben wird. Warum bezahlen da Leute Geld für?
Also erstmal heißt, freie Software sind Lizenzen, die unter der freien Software-Definition stehen oder unter der Open Source-Definition von dem Open Source Initiative und das ist eigentlich kurz zusammengefasst, gibt einem die Software vier Rechte. Das ist das Recht, die Software für jeden Zweck zu verwenden, die Software zu verstehen, also dafür braucht man den Quellcode der Software, die Software weiter zu verbreiten, also Kopien zu machen, weiterzugeben und die Software zu verändern, anzupassen an die eigenen Bedürfnisse. Das sind die vier Freiheiten, verwenden, verstehen, verbreiten, verbessern. Dann ist freie Software oder eben Open Source, wenn man den Marketingbegriff nutzen will. Und ja, das ist mal die Basis. Und jetzt, warum bezahlen da Leute dafür? Weil man in seinen Infrastruktur eben die kontrollieren will, weil man Probleme mit lösen will und dann will man dafür Software haben, die man die einem Probleme löst.
Darf ich mal ein Beispiel bringen?
Ja, bitte.
Zum Beispiel gab es lange Zeit Probleme, wenn man im Mac drucken wollte. Die haben angefangen, wie damals mit dem Laser Writer, und ging super. Und irgendwann, als die ganzen USB-Drucker angefangen haben, hatte Apple das Problem gehabt, dass die ganzen Drucker einfach nicht mehr funktionierten. Gleichzeitig haben sich ein paar Linux-Entwickler hingesetzt und haben ein System namens CUPS programmiert, was universelle Printer und Unterstützung für Linux an Start gebracht hat. Und als Apple da hingegangen ist, geil, das wollen wir, dann können wir endlich auch irgendwie alles, was man in den USB reinstecken kann, als Drucker benutzen und haben dann raue Mengen Geld auf die CUPS-Entwickler geworfen, denen sie es einfach geheihert haben. Und die haben dann für Apple gearbeitet und gleichzeitig dieses CUPS erstens auf so dieses Apple-Betriebssystem angepasst und gleichzeitig das Projekt trotzdem noch gepflegt.
Aber die wurden dann dafür bezahlt, dass sozusagen das nur eine ganz bestimmte Sache gemacht wurde, nämlich dass dieses CUPS auch für Apple Computer lief?
Nö, Apple hat dafür gesorgt, dass dieses CUPS noch weiter läuft, weil war ja auch zwischendurch unklar, ob es ein paar Open-Source-Programmierer auf ewig noch Lust haben, das zu betreiben. Also erstmal dafür gesorgt, dass die da committed bleiben zu diesem Projekt und dann natürlich auch immer wieder noch Treiber für neue Drucker wieder zurück in die Szene geben. Das fällt auch mit ab.
Der Punkt ist, du zahlst nicht direkt für eine Software-Lizenz, so wie wenn du dir Microsoft kaufst und dann x Euro zahlst für das Produkt, sondern es ist oft indirekt. Sei es du zahlst für Service und Support bei den großen Linux-Distributionen, sei es der Fall, den Erdgeist gerade genannt habe. Manchmal ist es auch einfach Marketing. Das ist aus Marketing, also Android würde ich das unterstellen, denen geht es ganz doll darum, viele Benutzer auf diese Plattform zu ziehen. Das darf auch erstmal nur Geld kosten, da muss man gar kein Geld verdienen im ersten Schritt. Also wo dann zum Schluss wie das Geld verdient wird, das kann sehr unterschiedlich durchaus sein.
Und also ein wichtiger Aspekt ist weiterhin, dass man selbst Infrastruktur benötigt, um etwas anderes, eine andere Dienstleistung zu erbringen und dann das einfach ein Teil von der Arbeit ist, dass man diese Infrastruktur pflegt. Und oft ist eben Freie Software eine Basisinfrastruktur für die ganzen großen Unternehmen, die irgendwelche Sachen im Internet machen und dafür braucht man halt Computer, die da laufen und dafür wird Freie Software dann verwendet. Und dann hast du selbst Entwickler, die ein Problem gerade lösen müssen. Und bevor sie das einfach nur lösen und bei sich in dem einen Unternehmen dann lösen, dann hat man mittlerweile immer mehr verstanden, dass es ein Interesse daran gibt, dass man diese Änderung wieder allen anderen zur Verfügung macht, dass das in der aktuellen Version, also in neueren Versionen, auch wieder mit drin ist, diese Änderung. Und deswegen haben immer mehr Unternehmen entwickeln zusammen, Basiskomponenten, die sie alle verwenden, also so eine Infrastruktur, die alle zusammen benutzen können nachher.
Okay, da hätte ich gedacht, dass der Weg dann ein anderer ist, dass nämlich das Unternehmen sagt, ha ha, es gibt so Open Source-Software, aber ich heure jetzt einen Entwicklern, der macht das besser, aber das behalte ich für mich selber, weil dann habe ich einen Wettbewerbsvorteil.
Das Problem ist, doch ein Entwickler reicht dir dann irgendwann nicht mehr. Je komplexer die Software ist, die du hast, an der Stelle, wo du dich wirklich entscheidest, dein eigenes Ding zu machen, dann musst du ja nicht nur deine eigenen Änderungen quasi verfolgen, sondern du musst die jeweils in neuere Versionen der Upstream-Software, also das Original, im Info-Zeichen integrieren. Du musst möglicherweise dafür sorgen, dass wenn sich das Original entscheidend ändert, genau an den Stellen, wo du gerade was geändert hast, dass das nachgezogen wird. Und das ist sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr aufwendig.
Ich dachte sozusagen, man kann einfach die Open Source-Software nehmen, man macht seine eigene Version, aber das ist sozusagen viel mit dem Vertrauen.
Das kann man machen, aber es ist weniger attraktiv, als man sich das auf den ersten Blick vorstellen mag.
Also das, was Marcus gerade gemeint hat, das haben früher die meisten Unternehmen erst mal gemacht. Die haben sich freie Software genommen und haben gesagt, wir haben ja aber noch ein Problem, das wollen wir ja noch lösen, sonst können wir unser Produkt nicht so ausliefern. Dann haben sie diese Entwicklung gemacht. Und wenn es dann da vielleicht einen Programmierer gab, der dann gemeint hat, ja, die Änderung will ich wieder zurückgeben, dann haben die Leute gesagt, vor allem in der Rechtsabteilung, nein, auf keinen Fall. Nicht unser Eigentum, was wir hier produziert haben, allen anderen kostenlos zur Verfügung stellen. Das dürfen wir nicht machen, das ist Firmenwert. Wir können nicht einfach Firmenwerte hier verschenken. Das ist damals am Anfang sehr stark mitgemacht worden. Was dann eben mitrealisiert worden ist, wenn ich jetzt solche Produkte längere Zeit pflegen will und meine Software mehrere Jahre pflegen will, dann habe ich jetzt eine Funktion eingebaut in die Software. Jetzt ist die unterliegende Free Software geändert worden. Das ist eine neue Version da. Die Änderungen, die ich gemacht habe, laufen da einfach nicht direkt. Ich muss da wieder Anpassungen machen, damit die Änderungen, die Funktionen, die ich eingebaut habe, bei der neuen Version auch laufen. Also muss ich nicht einmal Geld ausgeben, sondern ich muss jetzt das zweite Mal Geld ausgeben. Jetzt kommt die dritte Version. Das heißt, ich habe für die gleiche Funktion, die ich einmal eigentlich wollte, habe ich schon zweimal Geld ausgegeben. Und irgendwann hat man dann verstanden, dass wenn man diese Funktion einmal gerne implementieren will und dann in den nächsten zehn Jahren nutzen will, dass es eher sinnvoll ist, dass man diese Änderung wieder zurückbringt. Und mittlerweile werden Unternehmen eher dafür bezahlen, Entwickler dafür, die sagen, ich will, dass du die Änderung machst, aber ich will, dass die danach in die Hauptentwicklung von dem Freien Software-Projekt mit einfließt, damit ich nur einmal dafür bezahlen muss.
Und das hat für Open Source-Projekte, die das betrifft, auf der anderen Seite die Konsequenz. Sie müssen ganz genau aufpassen, was sie sich da eigentlich einschenken lassen von Drittanbieter, also von Kontributoren, von Leuten, die Code beitragen. Weil das Problem ist, jeden Code maintaine ich quasi umsonst für diese Person mit. Das heißt, ich muss mir ganz genau überlegen, ist das im Interesse nur dieses einen Menschen, nehme ich also diese Kontribution an? Oder sage ich, nee, das ist so selten, das ist so ein seltener Use-Case, das mache ich nicht. Das sollte man immer nur dann tun, wenn man davon überzeugt ist, dass die Mehrzahl der Benutzer das auch mitnehmen.
Jetzt bin ich aber verwirrt. Man ist jetzt froh, dass man Firmen gefunden hat, die werfen Geld rein, weil sie eine bestimmte Funktionalität wollen, sorgen dann auch dafür, dass diese bestimmte Funktionalität in die ursprüngliche Software mit eingebaut wird und sorgen so dafür, dass andere das auch machen. Jetzt sagt ihr, aber das will man vielleicht doch nicht. Das ist ja ein ganz schönes Durcheinander.
Da muss immer jemand testen. Also stell dir vor, ein großer Hardware-Hersteller hat irgendwie so ein... Ne, das ist noch zu Ende.
Nein, der Punkt ist schon klar, dass es da diese Bedenken geben kann, aber die Frage ist...
Ich will die ganz kurz, das wir sehr plastisch mal darstellen, als Subtreiber von dem Linux-Könnel.
Die Frage ist ja sozusagen, das sind die Leute, die dir das Geld geben. Wer sind denn diese anderen Leute, die jetzt was dagegen haben könnten?
Die Leute geben das Geld ja nicht direkt dem Projekt, sondern meistens...
Ne, dem Entwickler, genau, dem Entwickler, der diese Sache sozusagen programmiert.
Das muss ja nicht mal ein Entwickler aus dem Projekt selber sein. Das kann ja ein anderer Entwickler sein, der dann irgendeinen Wert schafft, der mit den eigentlichen Werten des ursprünglichen Projekts nicht viel gemein hat.
Aber das hört sich jetzt so an, als ob Geld immer nur an externe Entwickler geht, sozusagen aber nie an die Leute, die das Projekt direkt betreuen.
Das ist nicht der Punkt dabei. Der Punkt ist viel eher dabei, du hast ein Programm geschrieben, Open Source oder eine kleine Firma, das auf Linux läuft. Und jetzt kommt einmal eine Firma her und sagt, hier, porte mir das mal auf Windows, damit das auch da läuft. Dann geben die dir einmal Geld. Aber ab jetzt darfst du mit jeder Windows-Version immer wieder dein System updaten. Weil da ändert sich irgendetwas unten drunter, also musst du wieder Anpassungen bei dir. Es kann einfach einen riesigen Rattenschwanz haben. Mit jeder neuen Windows-Version musst du wieder kleine Änderungen machen, weil ab dem Moment, wo du es einmal gemacht hast, erwarten die Benutzer natürlich, ab jetzt muss es auf Windows immer laufen. Und das darf man nicht unterschätzen, was das nach sich ziehen kann, so eine kleine Änderung.
Ja klar, aber was du bis jetzt gesagt hast, es werfen Leute nur dann Geld auf Open Source-Entwicklung, um eine eigene Sache sozusagen neu reinzukriegen.
Nein, das war eins der Beispiele.
Ja, und was gibt es noch für welche?
Es gibt wie das Finanzieren von Konferenzen, dass die Entwickler mal zusammenkommen, wie ein Beispiel, so die Bild-Zeitung hat die Warnisch-Konferenz neulich geschmissen, weil die Bild-Zeitung ihre Paywall mit einem Warnisch gebaut hat.
Was ist denn Warnisch?
Der macht das Netz schneller, und zwar für eine Zeitung, die viele Kunden hat, die alle dieselben Inhalte gucken wollen, wo sich dann aber auch im Hintergrund die Inhalte schnell ändern, bei so einer Zeitung halt. Das sorgt dafür, dass die Informationen so schlau gecached werden, also direkt vorgehalten werden, dass viele Leute, die gleichzeitig vorbeikommen, auch schnell an die häufig benutzten Daten rankommen.
Vielleicht gehen wir noch mal ganz kurz bei dem Punkt ein bisschen zurück, damit wir noch mal verstehen, wie so ein freies Softwareprojekt hat verschiedene Ursprünge. Es kann einmal sein, da ist ein Entwickler, der macht das in seiner Freizeit. Das ist ein Hobbyprojekt und er startet damit. Jetzt wird die Software auf einmal relevant für Unternehmen. Jetzt ist die erste Frage, was machen dann die Unternehmen? Meistens versuchen die einen Hauptentwickler oder welche von den Hauptentwicklern von so einem Hobbyprojekt, dass sie die einstellen können, damit sie stärker Einfluss drauf nehmen können, in welche Richtung das geht. Jetzt kann das sein, dass bei dem Projekt so ist, dass ein, zwei Leute, die einen anderen Job haben, und sagen, das ist mir zu riskant, den Schritt zu gehen und mich für das Projekt bezahlen zu lassen. Ich mache das einfach in meiner Freizeit weiter. Dann müssen sich die Unternehmen jemand anderes suchen, den sie dafür bezahlen, dass er die Änderungen dort macht. Und dann ist es eben die Frage für jemanden, der das in seiner Freizeit macht. Wenn dann von außen jemand dafür bezahlt wird, Code beizusteuern, und das kommt dann rein, und da kommt vielleicht auch ziemlich viel rein, weil ich mache das in meiner Freizeit abends vier Stunden, und jetzt ist da auf einmal jemand, der macht das jetzt drei Monate Vollzeit, und der wirft auf einmal so ein Code-Batzen-Software auf mich. Da muss ich mir natürlich überlegen, kann ich denn das in meiner Freizeit überhaupt noch weiter machen? Das kann ich vielleicht bei dem ersten Mal machen, und dann werde ich das weiter entwickeln, aber beim zweiten Mal, dann wird es dann vielleicht schwer, wenn dann nochmal mehr kommt, oder nochmal mehr Unternehmen kommen, die noch mehr Software-Quellcode auf mich werfen. Und das ist ein Aspekt. Der andere ist natürlich, ich bin selbst ein Unternehmen, das freie Software schreibt, und jetzt kommen auf einmal zweite, dritte, vierte Firmen dazu, die auch Interesse an der Software haben und das mit mir zusammen machen wollen. Und da habe ich auch wieder, da kann ich als Unternehmen dafür bezahlt werden, dass ich die Änderungen mache, oder es kommen eben Leute dazu, und ich kann überlegen, will ich das zusammen mit denen machen? Haben wir gemeinsame Interessen? Wird das ein Projekt, an dem wir zusammenarbeiten, oder sind das unterschiedliche Projekte? Und ich sage so, nee, das nehme ich nicht mit rein, ich will nicht die Arbeit für euch mitmachen, diese Funktion weiterzuwarten, das müsst ihr selbst machen.
Aber da sind wir wieder an dem Punkt, dass sie sagen, also Geld fließt in der Open Source nur, wenn eine Firma daran interessiert ist.
Das ist genau ein Problem.
Nee, nicht nur. Es gibt andere Modelle, wie Geld zusammenkommt, durch Spenden zu weilen, durch einfach private, nicht von Firmen zusammengekratzte Kohle. Es gibt irgendwie Mäzenentum, auch in der Open-Source-Szene zu weilen. Was noch nicht so richtig beleuchtet worden ist, ist, dass du nicht automatisch, wenn dir Software geschenkt wird für dein Projekt, bist du mit der Qualität zufrieden. Viele Projekte haben eine ziemlich strikte Policy, was Dokumentation und was Review, sprich gegenseitiges Vier-Augen-Prinzip für Software, die in das Projekt reinkommt. Das heißt, da allein schon kann eine krasse Diskrepanz zwischen der verfügbaren Zeit eines bezahlten Entwicklers und eines Freizeitentwicklers kommen, dass der einfach den ganzen Code nicht mehr reviewen kann und dass er einfach sagen muss, nee, da werden bestimmte Coding-Standards nicht eingehalten, die einfach in diesem Projekt gar nicht gäbe sind. Ich kann deine Software einfach nicht annehmen, weil sie aus dem Mund riecht und morgen alle meine Installationen dann übernommen werden von irgendwelchen Bösen aus dem Internet, weil da einfach billigste Input-Valitation nicht passiert oder?
Also, dass sie sagen, das ist auch nochmal ein großer Posten, auch dass man sich die Software, die da eingerichtet wird, dass die sich auch nochmal jemand angucken muss. Also der große Posten an Arbeitszeit, der für Open Source-Software draufgeht, ist nicht nur, dass es überhaupt erst mal programmiert werden muss, sondern es ist auch noch, dass es jemand angucken muss. Also weil das ist ja, das heißt ja immer so, Open Source, ein offener Quellcode kann halt jeder gucken und schauen, ob das in Ordnung ist, aber es muss auch jemand machen und auch das ist dann nochmal viel Zeit.
Das kann vor allen Dingen richtig teuer werden. Wir haben öfter schon große Kontributionen zu unserem Open Source-Projekt gehabt, wo Leute uns mehrere hundert Zeilen Quellcode geschickt haben. Das kostet uns dann aber auch locker drei Wochen, die ordentlich durchzugucken und sie dem Projekt auch wirklich hinzuzufügen, weil zum Schluss müssen wir dafür gerade stehen und können nicht einfach sagen, ja apply mal den Patch und dann ist schon alles schön. Dann funktioniert vielleicht genau der Use-Case von demjenigen, der uns das geschickt hat, weil der mal wieder ein eigenes Interesse dahinter hatte. Aber der hat vielleicht auch nicht alle anderen Funktionalitäten jetzt durchgetestet, obwohl es eine Testsuit gibt, die selbstverständlich immer durchgelaufen werden lassen soll. Aber selbst dann hat man noch nicht 100 Prozent Sicherheit. Man muss da schon immer raufgucken. Und es ist halt wirklich die Frage, wie strikt man damit umgeht als Projekt. Ich habe bei Projekten mitgearbeitet, da waren sie halt froh über jeden Patch und mach mal. Das sind dann auch so die, wo ein oder zwei Personen hinterstehen und es gibt halt andere Projekte, in denen ich mitmache. Da brauchst du halt erst mal zwei Leute, die für deinen Code gerade stehen oder zumindest einen, der schon länger dabei ist. Und du brauchst das Plus-1 von einem Bot, das durchgeht und auf formalen Kleinkram checkt, wie hast du deine Änderungen sauber dokumentiert, sodass hinterersichtlich ist, was du getan hast etc. Also eher Formalien, die man auch automatisch prüfen kann.
Also wir haben das sozusagen schon gehört, es gibt also zwei große Posten, nämlich einmal das Programmieren, dann noch sozusagen das Durchgucken. Wir haben auch gehört, Danimo und Lasse sind da Teil an solchen Projekten, wo auch genau damit gearbeitet und auch Geld verdienen wird. Das hören wir uns gleich an, hier im Chaosradio 209, das heute in der Marienstrasse 11 in Berlin live produziert und gesendet wird. Ihr könnt gerne noch vorbeikommen. Jetzt gibt es ein kleines bisschen Musik und zwar von den Blurred Superheroes Stop Speaking. Und damit sind wir wieder da im Chaos Radio 209 aus der Marienstrasse 11 aus dem Chaos Computer Club in Berlin. Und das war ein neuer Vorschlag für einen Chaos Radio Opener. Wir suchen ja seit geraumer Zeit einen neuen Opener, eine neue Openermusik, haben jetzt von Alec Empire, was er vom vorletzten Kongress als Musik gemacht hat, als Titeltrack genommen und es haben viele Leute gesagt, na, kann man da nicht mal was Neues, es ist zu lang, zu laut, zu leise, zu kurz. Also es gab vielfältiges Gemecker und wir haben gesagt, na dann macht doch mal. Zwei Vorschläge haben wir uns erreicht, aber da ist noch Platz und Luft nach oben, also ihr könnt gerne noch Dinge einreichen, wenn ihr wollt, dann Chaosradio at ccc.de. Dieser Vorschlag kommt von Arne Bense und wir hören nachher noch einen anderen. Es geht heute um Open Source-Finanzierung. Wir haben in der ersten halben Stunde erst mal die Grundlagen geklärt. Die Grundlagen sind, Programmierung ist aufwendig und auch das Checken dieses Quellcodes, also das, was programmiert wurde, dass man auch testet, dass es überhaupt stimmt. Das braucht beides viel Zeit und das wäre schon gut, wenn die Leute, die das machen, irgendwie davon leben können. Und das findet anscheinend vor allem dadurch statt, dass Firmen dafür bezahlen, weil sie bestimmte Open Source-Software selber benutzen und dann Entwicklungen finanzieren, an denen sie persönlich interessiert sind. Jetzt haben wir hier zwei Leute im Chaos-Radio neben Erdgeist und Matthias Kirschner vom SF-SFE, die selber mit der Programmierung von Open Source-Software Geld verdienen, also die quasi angestellt sind. Das ist der Lasse, hallo nochmal, und der Danimo. Und jetzt könnt ihr mal bitte beide erzählen, was ihr genau macht und wieso euch Leute für was bezahlen lasst. Fang nochmal an.
Ja, das mit dem Angestellt wäre ja schon mal schön.
Achso, wie ist das bei dir? Wann arbeitest du?
Ständig und selbst, also selbstständig. Ich arbeite in zwei Open Source-Projekten seit 2006, dass ich davon lebe und das hauptberuflich mache seit 2007. Und wir sind in dem einen Projekt alles Selbstständige und finanzieren uns, indem wir mit unserer eigenen Software dann Projekte annehmen, weil wir uns am besten auskennen mit dieser Software. Und das Geld dazu nutzen, um in unserem Produkt weiterzuentwickeln. Also querfinanzieren sozusagen.
Die Rechnung ist quasi, ihr habt eine Software gemacht und dann bezahlen euch Leute dafür, dass diese Software etwas Bestimmtes kann oder auf eine bestimmte Art und Weise eingerichtet wird. Ihr nehmt dann so viel Geld, dass ihr davon auch bezahlen könnt, dass ihr die eigentliche Software weiterentwickelt. Das ist quasi die Rechnung.
Ganz genau. Die wollen dann irgendeinen Spezialfall erfüllt wissen oder haben ein spezielles Szenario, brauchen neue Funktionalität, die das Produkt noch nicht hat, die wir im Rahmen eines Projekts dann, das sind die schönen Projekte, wo wir dann eine neue Funktionalität entwickeln dürfen. Im Idealfall, die auch wieder Open Sourcen dürfen. Da probieren wir eigentlich immer, drauf zu bestehen. Das ist uns auch bis jetzt immer gelungen. Und ja, so funktioniert es.
Das heißt, ihr seid darauf angewiesen, dass da immer wieder neue Aufträge reinkommen. Kann man sich auf sowas verlassen?
Meistens ja, erstaunlicherweise. Also unser Marketing ging jahrelang gegen Null. Und trotzdem kamen immer wieder Leute auf uns zu, die Interesse dran hatten, eben mit dieser Software etwas zu machen, sie weitertreiben wollten, neue Funktionalitäten benötigten. Das hat oftmals gut funktioniert.
Was ist das für eine Software, wo Leute jahrelang immer wieder neue Dinge wollen oder die total geil finden?
Das eine ist eine sogenannte X-Forms-Implementierung. X-Forms ist ein W3C-Standard, genauso wie HTML ein W3C-Standard ist. Es ist sogar der Nachfolger von HTML. War mal so angedacht, hat nicht ganz funktioniert, der Plan vom W3C an der Stelle. Und da haben wir eine von mehreren Implementierungen geschrieben. Und das andere Projekt, in dem ich arbeite, ist eine NoSQL-Datenbank, die auf XML spezialisiert ist, also auch ein W3C-Standard an der Stelle.
Das sind aber nicht Dinge, die es nicht auch anderswo schon gibt, und die technischen Grundlagen auch liefern für das, was man im Webso treibt.
Kann man das so sagen? Na, als wir angefangen haben mit der X-Forms-Implementierung, da gab es zum Beispiel noch keine. Da hat wirklich das W3C einen Standard entwickelt, gerade zu der Zeit, wo wir eine der allerersten Implementierungen zugeschrieben haben, um das auch mal möglich zu machen. Der große Wunschraum des W3C war es damals, dass Browser diesen Standard in sich einbauen und das nativ verstehen, dass soweit ist es nie gekommen.
Zum Glück für uns. Ist das jetzt vergleichbar mit einem ganz normalen, anderen Programmiererjob als freier Programmierer? Also das Programmierer, freie und selbstständige Arbeit ist jetzt nicht so ungewöhnlich. Hast du das für dich irgendwie vor der Nachteile, das auf diese Art und Weise zu machen, also mit Open Source?
Im Vergleich zu anderen Selbstständigen ist wahrscheinlich wirklich nicht groß der Unterschied, die sich auch um oder in einer kleinen Bürogemeinschaft, die müssen sich auch um mehr als das reine Entwickeln kümmern. Es ist halt sehr vielseitig. Ich muss sowohl zum Kunden raus, mit dem die Verhandlungen führen, als auch ein Projekt umsetzen, als auch mir einen Kopf machen, wie wir unser Produkt weiterentwickeln. Also es ist eher der Unterschied zu einer Festanstellung, wo ich als Software-Entwickler an einem Produkt ein halbes Jahr lang zu einem Thema arbeite. Da ist es bei uns deutlich vielseitiger, würde ich sagen, weil man eben all die verschiedenen Funktionen erfüllen muss. Und sei es, dass man sich die eigene Homepage selber schreibt, anstatt einen Grafiker zu beauftragen, das zu machen.
Dann letzte Frage noch, also die Software, die ihr macht, ist Software, die wird auch von Software-Entwicklern gebraucht. Das ist sozusagen jetzt nicht, wo ich als User hingehe und sage, hier, ich werde jetzt gerne ein X-Form Dingsbums. Glaubst du, dieses Modell könnte auch benutzt werden mit einem Software, die für End-User gemacht werden?
Ich glaube sogar eher einfacher, weil je größer die Basis an Benutzern ist, umso leichter ist es dann auch, was zurückbekommen zu bekommen. Sei es in Form von Spenden, Unterstützung, dass Leute einem helfen, die Dokumentation zu übersetzen oder Ähnliches.
Ich dachte, ich hätte eher gedacht, der User im Internet ist mittlerweile so gewöhnt, dass es alles umsonst gibt, dass es da schwieriger ist, während Leute, die auch technisch Ahnung haben und dann von dir, der du technisch Ahnung hast, was haben willst, dann eher bereit sind, Geld zu bezahlen, weil sie halt wissen, was dahinter steckt.
Ja, das Problem bei den Leuten, die technisch auch Ahnung haben und gerade in diesem W3C-Umfeld, die arbeiten alle selber in Open Source-Projekten oder Glieder von denen. Das sind auch nicht die, die auf der Überholspur mit Geld um sich schmeißen können.
Die Sichtbarkeit von so Projekten im Frontend ist auch größer. Und im Zweifel kann ein Projekt mit viel User-Unterface auch mal noch im Fenster aufmachen, wo er schön gespendet und ist dann mehr Rücklauf an Aufmerksamkeit, vielleicht Danksagung und Geld.
Also können wir ganz ehrlich sagen, wir haben in den zehn Jahren insgesamt 500 DM an Spenden bekommen. Und es ist nicht so, dass nicht mehrfach dazu aufgerufen wurde.
Okay, na gut, Danimo, was arbeitest du denn und wer bezahlt dich wofür?
Also ich habe den angenehmenen Pfad. Ich bin angestellt tatsächlich. Also bin erstmal in erster Linie Software-Entwickler. Kollegen von mir, ich hatte in meinem ersten Job Kollegen, die mit Open Source eigentlich überhaupt nichts am Mut haben, die das tatsächlich ganz normal als Software-Entwickler gemacht haben und denen das in erster Linie tatsächlich egal war, in welchem Umfeld sie das tun. Ich tue das schon in dem Bewusstsein, dass das Open Source oder Free Software ist. Das heißt, ich möchte mit der Community zusammenarbeiten. Das führt natürlich dann immer mal wieder zu Konflikten. Die Community ist möglicherweise schneller dabei, mit dir zusammenzuarbeiten. Mit Kunden läufst du üblicherweise erstmal durch den Support durch, was dann zum einen natürlich gut ist, weil du idealerweise präzisere Anforderungen hast, wo du dich erstmal mit der Community quasi auskaspern musst.
Ich muss aber hier schon mal nachfragen, was ist denn der Unterschied zwischen einem Kunden und einem Kunden? Weil jemand, der die Software benutzt und jemand, der die Software benutzt und dir Geld gibt, beschreitet sich für mich jetzt erstmal nur dadurch, dass er dir Geld gibt. Aber warum tut er das?
Er tut das, weil er darauf angewiesen ist, dass ich für ihn Änderungen vornehme in dem Produkt. Das ist es teilweise einfach. Ich rolle das am besten mal wirklich historisch auf. Ich habe zuerst bei einer Bibliothek QT gearbeitet. Stell dir vor, du möchtest ein Programm schreiben für möglichst viele Betriebssysteme, also auf dem Desktop. Dann kannst du entweder das Programm für jedes Betriebssystem neu schreiben oder du hast eine Bibliothek drunter, die das für dich übernimmt. Du schreibst quasi den Programmcode nur einmal und nimmst dann minimale Anpassungen ans Betriebssystem nur noch vor, wo es halt gar nicht anders geht. Das ist ja erstmal eine Dienstleistung, wo man sagen würde, okay, das ist mir etwas wert. Tatsächlich war die Software vorher so, dass du als Firma, wenn du selber deine Software nicht unter einer freien Lizenz gestellt hast, dafür bezahlen musstest. Das war also noch nicht richtig Open Source. Das ist dann Stück für Stück in eine volle GPL und dann später LGPL-Lizenzierung.
Das sind verschiedene Lizenzen zur Open Source?
Das sind verschiedene Lizenzen. Was wichtig dabei ist, ist im Prinzip, es wurde immer egaler, unter welcher Lizenz du selber deine Software verbreitest. Du konntest diese Software eigentlich immer benutzen, diese Bibliothek, ohne uns in irgendeiner Form etwas zurückzugeben.
Womit kam dann da Geld rein?
Genau. Die Firma Trolltech ist irgendwann von Nokia aufgekauft worden. Nokia hat gesagt, eigentlich wollen wir das nur für unsere Telefone haben. Und wenn das andere mitentwickeln, ist das schön, aber wir haben eigentlich kein Interesse mehr daran, mit der Bibliothek Geld zu verdienen. Das ist natürlich schön für alle, die das irgendwie drumherum verwenden. Nur umgekehrt hast du jetzt natürlich, bzw. die Leute, die jetzt damit versuchen, Geld zu verdienen, seit Nokia da nicht mehr mit dem Boot ist. Die haben natürlich das Problem, jetzt wieder Geld damit zu verdienen, weil natürlich jetzt auch große Anbieter, große Firmen sagen, ja, auch eigentlich, vielleicht nehmen wir irgendwie so das Support-Paket, aber Entwicklerlizenzen für die Software selber brauchen wir nicht zu bezahlen. Eigentlich ist die Lizenz, gibt uns so viele Freiheiten. Ich weiß, wenn ich jetzt Freiheiten sage, wird er mich wieder komisch angucken.
Er meinte, Matthias Kirschner, man kann immer mal ein Fest-of-Elektrode machen.
Aber ich habe im Prinzip so viele Möglichkeiten, werde nicht damit eingeschränkt, was ich mit meinem Code machen kann. Ich brauche da eigentlich nichts von denen einzukaufen. Und das ist genau das Problem, vor dem QT heute steht. Und später, um jetzt mal weiterzugehen, ich arbeite aktuell an dem Desktop Client für On Cloud. Das ist eben auch C++ und verwendet, tada, auch QT als Bibliothek. Und das Schöne ist, ich bin jetzt auf der anderen Seite. Ich bin jemand, der, wenn er etwas findet, quasi die Fehlerbehebung nach QT zurückgibt. Ich durchlaufe also deren Prozess, um kurz zurückzugeben, lasse den Code anschauen, setze mich da der Kritik aus und kann das zurückgeben.
Aber nochmal die Frage. On Cloud, das ist ja z.B. bei On Cloud zu sagen, also die bietet quasi so Cloud-Dienste, die man nicht mal auf meinem eigenen Rechner installieren kann. Und ich kann mir diese Software umsonst runterladen. Soweit ich gesehen habe, kann ich die auch gar nicht kaufen, sondern das ist halt einfach so ein Ding. Wer bezahlt da jetzt irgendwie die Firma dafür, die dich dann bezahlt, damit du deine Brötchen essen kannst?
Genau, du kannst dir, das hast du richtig gesagt, das einfach runterladen. Aber es gibt erstens Leute, die das in richtig großen Umgebungen einsetzen. Die möchten natürlich irgendwie ein bisschen Hilfe dabei haben, das aufgesetzt zu bekommen. Die möchten sehr, sehr schnelle Reaktionszeiten haben. Also nicht erst über einen Backtrecker laufen, sondern die möchten halt hier bei uns klemmt was, könnt ihr dann mal gerade gucken und das muss halt schnell gehen. Das muss innerhalb von garantierten Zeiten laufen etc. Also um solche Garantien zu haben, möchtest du also schon in irgendeiner Form einen Vertrag mit uns abschließen.
Hast du denn nicht einen Interessenskonflikt, die Dokumentation vielleicht an allen Stellen absichtlich schleifen zu lassen, dass Leute bei dir Installation ganz dringend einkaufen müssen?
Na ja, wenn du, wenn du natürlich darauf aus bist, so viel User wie möglich zu haben und gleichzeitig nicht das Budget hast, um super viele Entwickler und Doku-Leute und so einzukaufen, möchtest du deine Dokumentation so gut und so fokussiert wie möglich haben. Weil sonst hast du nämlich das Problem, dass du gar nicht mehr Kunden annehmen kannst, weil du ständig dabei bist, deinen bestehenden Kunden irgendwie dasselbe noch mal zu erklären. Du bist also gerade sehr gut daran, deinen Kunden und auch deinen normalen Benutzern, die später mal zahlende Kunden werden, weil sie noch einen Feature brauchen oder weil sie eben die garantierte Antwortzeit brauchen, denen so gut wie möglich Dokumentation zur Verfügung zu stellen.
Also aber ein One-Click-Installations-Skript für das Ganze, mit wem einen ordentlichen Wizard würde dir denn den Job wegnehmen?
Ne, eben nicht. Das gibt es ja. Nur wenn du jetzt irgendwie das in einem speziellen Cluster-Szenario mit spezieller Hardware, mit spezieller Software, das kann ich in so einem One-Click-Skript einfach nicht mehr abbilden und solche speziellen Fälle, die kann ich dann supporten mit einer Firma.
Und ich meine, also der zweite Punkt ist, neben dem ist es jetzt, wie schwer ist es, das zu installieren. In manchen Unternehmen, wenn du so eine Software einführst, da willst du jemanden haben, der schuld ist, wenn das nicht funktioniert. Und der, der die Software dort einführen will, will vielleicht nicht der sein, der dann nachher schuld ist, wenn die Software nicht funktioniert. Also bezahlst du jemand anderes Geld dafür, dass wenn was nicht funktioniert, dass du sagen kannst, die sind schuld.
Jetzt, je weiter die Sendung geht, desto mehr drängt sich mir der Gedanke auch, dass das Open Source Software irgendwie gar nicht oder Free Software gar nicht so das ist, was ich dachte, weil ich dachte mal, dahinter steht so das Ideal, dass möglichst viele Menschen möglichst weitreichend befähigt werden sollen, mit dieser Software umzugehen. Aber wenn ich mir die Geldströme angucke, die hier so fließen, dann ist es ja tatsächlich sozusagen, ist es das Business, das regiert, wie alles in der Welt. Und das heißt, ich würde mir das schon vorstellen, das ist auch ein Fall wie On Cloud, dass die, das könnte ich mir vorstellen, dass wenn es darum geht, wird das Produkt jetzt weiterentwickelt, dass es dann halt erst mal entwickelt wird im Hinsicht auf, wer zahlt das Geld? Und ist das nicht so ein Problem oder habe ich mir dieses Ideal nur eingebildet, gibt es das eigentlich gar nicht?
Das kommt immer aufs Projekt an. Es gibt Projekte, die will ich einfach nicht so niedergeredet wissen. Es gibt einfach Hobbyisten-Projekte, die sind echt gut und die sind ordentlich dokumentiert. Da haben Leute Anspruch an sich selber und die tun das in ihrer Freizeit und die tun das in ihrer Freizeit auch sehr gut. Und sie haben auch People-Skills, um eine Community aufzubauen, wo viele Kontributoren angelockt werden, die erwachsen sind und niemandem was beweisen müssen und dann wie auch mit brauchbaren Patches ankommen und die sich einfach in der Community zusammenfinden und dann schon wohl miteinander fühlen. Da muss man kein Geld hinterher werfen. Also das ist ja eins der oft unterschätzten Fakten ist, wenn irgendjemand ein Sackgesicht ist und im Keller wie alleine an Software hinfrickelt und jedes Mal, wenn irgendjemand ihm vielleicht Patches schickt, garstige Mails zurückschickt und die Community nicht ordentlich pflegt, wird er auch auf Dauer ein Problem haben und muss im Zweifel mit Geld gepimpert werden. Wenn, so zum Beispiel Python, die Community von Pyramid zum Beispiel fühlt sich im Allgemeinen sehr erwachsen an, wo auch so ein sehr hoch fokussierter Nerd dran ist.
Lass mich die Eintrache noch ein bisschen weiter tun. Es gibt also Open Source funktioniert, dann wird Firmengeld drauf werfen oder wenn technisch interessierte Leute persönlich sich in diesem Projekt involvieren. Alle positiven Beispiele, die ohne Geld funktionieren, die ich heute gehört habe, die sind halt eher in die Richtung von Programmierern für Programmierer. Und was ich ja immer gedacht habe, ist, es geht darum, dass der normale User, also der nicht-techie quasi, dass der auch davon profitieren kann, dass aus dieser Community Software rausfällt. Und das scheint mir so ein bisschen…
Zum Schluss kannst du mit unserer Software ja Anwendungen bauen von der der normale User…
Ich kann eben keine Anwendungen bauen. Das ist ja genau der Punkt.
Du sprichst da gerade mit falschen Leuten. Andere Entwickler können das und da kommt für den Endanwender auch wieder was raus. Die haben freie Software zum Beispiel von uns zur Verfügung gestellt. Und ich würde schon sagen, dass zumindest in meinem Umfeld da bei XSDB und Betafem, das sind alles Überzeugungstäter. Wegen dem Geld macht das bei uns ganz sicher keiner, dass sie besser in einem Angestelltenverhältnis aus auf dem Lohnzettel mit Sicherheit. Also es hat schon… Weil du gerade sagtest, es wird nicht aus Überzeugung gemacht. Doch, doch, das wird sehr wohl aus Überzeugung gemacht.
Genau, es wird schon über Überzeugung gemacht, aber es sind dann immer so Projekte, wo es dann auch wieder auf ihren Weg geht. Was ist denn mit GIMP? GIMP ist ganz schlimm. Niemand benutzt GIMP. Ich kenne tatsächlich selber niemanden, der GIMP freiwillig benutzt.
Mitch, der programmiert es auch.
Also ich denke, was für Motive dahinter sind, wenn jemand freie Software schreibt, das ist erstmal auch so ein bisschen zweitrangig. Weil, selbst wenn jetzt ein Unternehmen ist, was einfach eine Software schreibt, die kümmern sich nicht um irgendwelche anderen Kontributoren, das ist denen alles egal, die erfüllen damit die Kundenwünsche von ihrem einen Kunden. Und die lassen niemanden anders irgendwelche Änderungen daran in ihrem Zweig, also in ihrem Repository machen, sondern sagen, wir entwickeln mit unseren fünf Leuten diese Software und kümmert der Rest der Welt nicht. Dann ist das trotzdem so, dass wenn das freie Software ist, dann steht das unter einer Lizenz, die einem auf jeden Fall ermöglicht, dass wenn man gerne was anderes hätte, dass man das anders machen kann. Wenn ich selbst nicht programmieren kann, dann habe ich in dem Moment auf jeden Fall die Möglichkeit, dass ich jemand anders dafür bezahle, dass er für mich Änderungen macht und dass die Software für mich anpasst und das irgendwie anders betreibt. Oder ich habe die Möglichkeit, dass ich selber programmieren lerne, dass ich mir den kompletten Quellcode angucke, dass ich lerne, wie das funktioniert und dass ich mich da rein arbeite. Das ist natürlich viel, viel aufwendiger. Bei kleinen Sachen funktioniert das, bei anderen Sachen habe ich aber die Möglichkeit, dass ich jemanden tritte, der sich auskennt, dafür bezahlen kann. Und das die Möglichkeit habe ich bei unfreier Software nicht. Da entwickeln die Unternehmen die Software, die geben mir die Software, aber niemand anderes außer denen, denen dieses Unternehmen das erlaubt, kann Änderungen daran machen. Das heißt, ich habe einen Dienstleistungsmonopol auf die Software. Ich bestimme, was mit der Software gemacht werden darf, was für Anwendungszwecke die haben darf, kann ich in der Lizenz mitbestimmen. Ich kann damit bestimmen, wer sonst daran entwickeln darf. Das kann ich damit kontrollieren. Und das ist bei Free Software immer so, dass das eben nicht der Fall ist. Sondern Free Software gibt einem als Anwender immer die Möglichkeit, dass ich meine eigene Infrastruktur kontrollieren kann.
Und noch mal zu dem Punkt von eben von dir. Linux ist als sehr bekannte freie Open Source, wird von vielen Endanwendern eingesetzt. LibreOffice findet häufig Verwendung. Also es ist schon so, dass die Enduser jede Menge inzwischen von Open Source haben. In ihrem täglichen Leben. Gerade an der Stelle, wo du jetzt LibreOffice gesagt hast, was ja auch maßgeblich von Sun zum Beispiel finanziert wurde und eigentlich schon immer einen kommerziellen Background hatte, zumindest als es noch Open Office hieß. Mittlerweile ist es etwas anders. Aber ganz ursprünglich als StarOffice ja nicht. Doch, doch. Da war es doch Open Source. Nee, da war es sogar noch Closed Source.
Wir verlieren gerade alle, die sich nicht in den historischen Details von der Open Source Microsoft Office Alternativen auskennen. Was ist der Punkt jetzt bei LibreOffice?
Sowohl LibreOffice als auch der Linux-Könner haben das Problem, das sind sehr komplexe Projekte. Und sie werden auch tendenziell nur komplexer. Also Systeme haben immer das Problem, dass sie eher komplexer als einfacher werden. Und je komplexer etwas wird, desto eher hast du halt auch das Problem, dass du als einzelne Person nicht mehr durchsteigen kannst, wenn du dich nur mal irgendwie gerade drei Stunden am Abend damit befassen kannst. Das heißt, die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass hinter komplexeren Projekten jemand steckt, der da irgendwie sein Leben und sein Brötchen mitfinanzieren kann, ist halt höher.
Aber wer bezahlt das dann? Also wer bezahlt irgendwie die Linux-Körner? Machen das dann die Firmen, die mit Linux-Servern arbeiten?
Da hast du ja den Vorteil, der Körner ist ja Schnittstelle zum Hardware. Das heißt, du hast schon mal die ganzen Hardware-Ersteller, die einfach Interesse haben, Kraft der Marktmacht von von Linux. Kann man ja mittlerweile wirklich so sagen, gerade bei Servern, aber halt auch im Embedded-Bereich beispielsweise. Das heißt, es gibt Firmen, die haben ein Interesse, dass ihre Hardware Linux-kompatibel ist. So und das heißt, alleine diese Firmen bezahlen schon mal Leute, die zu Linux-Code hinzufügen, in Form von beispielsweise Treibern oder auch, wenn ich als Firma erkenne, okay, die Infrastruktur im Körner, die, was weiß ich, irgendwelche Funktionalität, die ich gerade einbauen will, unterstützt das nicht gut genug, da braucht man was Neues, dass man also auch sogar nicht nur Treiber, sondern ganz neue Konzepte in den Körner einbaut. Aber das braucht halt Leute, die das halt in der Regel sich damit ein bisschen auskennen. Das machst du halt nicht mal eben so nach der Arbeit. Das gab es noch zu Zeiten, als man zum Beispiel ESDN-Support eingebaut hat. Ich glaube, da gab es Leute, die das teilweise aus Eigenantrieb gemacht haben. Aber es wird schwierig irgendwann. Es wird einfach irgendwann schwierig, wenn du nicht zum Beispiel einen Job in der Uni hast, der dir irgendwie oder im akademischen Bereich generell erlaubt, da ein bisschen Zeit rein zu investieren, ohne dass das jetzt dein primär Fokus ist, dann mag das gehen. Aber es wird schwierig, einfach aus Privatzeit das dort zu schöpfen. Beim Linux-Könnel ist es ganz konkret zum Beispiel die Linux Foundation, die da sehr viel Geld bei steuert, unter anderem Linus Torvalds finanziert. Die Foundation setzt sich aus, ich glaube, 200 Unternehmen zusammen, wo namhafte Leute bei sind, wie eben Adobe ist da mit drin, Intel ist dabei. Also die ganze große Palette Google ist da mit drin. Die alle irgendwie über direkt oder indirekten Interesse haben, dass es Linux gibt, die sind bereit, in diese Foundation Geld zu stecken. Und die Foundation sorgt dann dafür, dass ausgewählte Entwickler oder Projekte, wie es ganz genau läuft, weiß ich auch nicht. Und dass nicht dann dafür gesorgt wird, dass es vorwärts geht.
Wobei die Linux Foundation dort gar nicht so der Großteil ist. Also es gibt auf lwn.net, die machen das einmal, mindestens einmal im Jahr machen, die eine Analyse, von wem solche Contributions zu dem Linux-Könnel kommen und da hast du die ganzen großen Unternehmen drin. Du weißt, wie HP, IBM, da hast du drin Oracle, da hast du dann drin Google, da hast du drin Facebook, da ist drin Amazon, die ganzen großen Unternehmen, die sind da alle drin und dann hast du auch noch ein paar, die kannst du nicht direkt zuordnen, weil das Entwickler sind, die bezahlt werden von einem von den Unternehmen und halt noch ihre Privatadresse zum Beispiel auch mit nutzen, weil die schon sehr, sehr lange Zeit Kernel-Entwickler sind und dann halt von dem Kunden mal ein Projekt annehmen oder von einem anderen Kunden ein Projekt annehmen, aber beim Linux-Könnel ist, wie Daniel schon gesagt hat, mittlerweile so, dass das so komplex ist und auch so ein wichtiger Bestandteil ist. Ich meine, müssen wir uns mal überlegen, wo der Linux-Könnel heute überall drin ist. Wenn wir dort Probleme reinbekommen, dann haben wir auf einmal eine Vielzahl der Rechner auf der Erde, funktioniert auf einmal nicht mehr mehr, wenn da Probleme reinkommen.
Deswegen ist auch Hauptteil der Arbeit, die Linux Torwalz gerade macht, nicht mehr programmieren, sondern der macht klassisches Projektmanagement. Der macht, wie die Patches angucken, die da reinkommen und dafür sorgen, dass Kotqualität gewahrt wird und dass die Flicken da zusammenpassen.
Okay, dann haben wir jetzt also eine Stunde lang geklärt, was man bei Open Source-Software finanzieren kann und muss und dass es eigentlich gar kein großes Problem ist, so was ihr bis jetzt erzählt habt. Da frage ich mich natürlich, wie ist denn das bei GnuPG schiefgegangen? Also fast schiefgegangen. Wir klären das gleich. Wir hören vorhin noch eine kleine Musik von Stony Broder Jr. Let the Jungle Grow. Stony, Broder Jr. Let the Jungle Grow und wir sind natürlich beim Chaosradio und das geht natürlich nicht ohne die passenden Nachrichten dazu, die diesmal präsentiert werden von Fiona.
Die Nerd-News Lenovo hat auf einige Notebook-Serien Ende 2014 die Software Superfish vorinstalliert. Superfish installiert ein eigenes SSL-Root-Zertifikat in Windows. Damit kann Superfish auch eigene Werbung in Webseiten einbauen, die Verschlüsse zwischen Webbrowser und Servern im Internet übertragen werden. Besonders brisant dabei ist, dass sowohl der Private Key als auch dessen Passwort mit der Software ausgeliefert wurden und nun im Internet kursieren. Dadurch ist es sehr einfach, den betroffenen Rechnern gefälschte Websites unterzuschieben. Die verwendete Technologie stammt von der Firma Komodia und findet auch in anderen Produkten Verwendung. Das US-Cert pflegt eine Liste mit solchen kritischen Produkten, die ihr in den Shownotes findet. Der Antivirus-Hersteller Kaspersky hat verdächtigen Code einer bislang unbekannten kriminellen Hackergruppe untersucht. Dabei ist Kaspersky auf Trojaner gestoßen, welche die Firmware von Festplatten infizieren können. Indizien deuten darauf hin, dass die Gruppe, von Kaspersky Equation Group getauft, enge Kontakte zu NSA unterhält. Nach Thunder Strike und Bad USB ist damit Malware für eine weitere PC-Komponente bestätigt, die auch eine Neuinstallation des Betriebssystems übersteht. Der Film Citizen 4 der US-Filmemacherin Laura Poitras ist in der Kategorie beste Reportage mit einem Oscar ausgezeichnet worden. Citizen 4 zeigt den ersten Teil von Edward Snowden's Flucht. Er begleitet den Whistleblower bei seinen ersten Treffen mit Poitras und dem Journalisten Glenn Greenwald in einem Hotel in Hongkong. Doch nicht allen schmeckt der Film. Ein ehemaliger amerikanischer Navy-Offizier strebt ein Gerichtsprozess gegen Poitras und die Produktionsfirma Weinstein Company wegen angeblicher Veröffentlichung von Staatsgeheimnissen an.
Ja, hallo und herzlich willkommen zurück zur zweiten Hälfte vom Chaos Radio 209, wo es um Open Source-Finanzierung geht, in der Marienstraße 11 im Chaos Computer Club Berlin, wo ihr gerne auch noch vorbeikommen könnt. Und die Sendung fing, nahm eine erstaunliche Wendung. Also es fing ja an mit, es gibt den aktuellen Anlass, GnuPG, eine weit verbreitete Open Source Verschlüsselungssoftware, hatte nicht genug Spenden zusammenbekommen und das ist dann, hat dann doch noch irgendwie geklappt. Aber in dem Zuge gab so eine große Diskussion darum, wie Open Source-Projekte überhaupt finanziert werden können. Wir haben jetzt eine Stunde darüber geredet. Ich habe festgestellt, teuer ist vor allem, dass das erst mal programmiert werden muss, dass es sehr komplex werden kann und dass dieser Code natürlich auch durchgeguckt werden muss. Und dann haben wir eigentlich die ganze Stunde darüber geredet, wie gut das mit der Finanzierung eigentlich funktioniert. Also ja, das Geld kommt dann irgendwie von Firmen, die sich aus verschiedenen Beweggründen an Open Source-Projekten beteiligen. Da muss man auch ein bisschen aufpassen, dass sie nicht zu viel machen. Aber letztendlich ist da irgendwie Geld da. Und da frage ich mich natürlich, wenn das alles funktioniert und auch wir gerade von zwei Leuten gehört haben, haben die also wirklich Jobs oder sich zumindest damit finanzieren, was den Lebensunterhalt angeht, indem sie Open Source-Software programmieren. Warum, wie kam es denn zu diesem GnuPG-Problem? Was war denn da los? Gab es da nicht genug Interesse von den Firmen oder was ist da los?
Also aus meiner Sicht ist es so gewesen, dass erstmal, wir haben jetzt hier über viele Sachen gesprochen, in denen das funktioniert. Auf der anderen Seite gibt es auch viele Unternehmen, die nehmen sich freie Software, benutzen die und haben dafür nie irgendjemand Geld gegeben, sondern nutzen das einfach und das funktioniert.
Das ist ja auch ein gutes Recht jetzt erstmal. Moralisch vielleicht nicht, aber rechtlich auf jeden Fall.
Das ist auch moralisch erstmal okay. Das einzige, was eben die Schwierigkeit ist, ist, wenn jetzt dort ein Problem aufkommt, wer ist dann dafür verantwortlich? Also ich habe eine Infrastruktur und jetzt ist es ja meistens nicht so, wenn ich jetzt ein großes Unternehmen habe, habe ich teilweise jetzt von den großen Internetanbietern, die haben ja auch sehr viele Daten dort, und wenn die jetzt dafür sorgen wollen, dass ihre Software eigentlich sicher ist und dass die Daten bei denen bleiben, dann sollten sie eigentlich gucken, dass sie in ihre Infrastruktur investieren. Also schauen, dass da immer wieder jemand drüber guckt, ist das denn noch sicher, oder gehen dann auf einmal Daten verloren und auf einmal sind meine ganzen Kundendaten von der Versicherung in der Öffentlichkeit. Und da ist es halt in der Vergangenheit jetzt sehr oft so gewesen, dass in solche Komponenten nicht investiert worden ist. Meiner Ansicht nach auch deswegen, weil wenn dort was passiert, also wenn ich ein sicheres Problem habe, dann tut das mir wirtschaftlich nicht besonders weh. Also warum sollte ich in was investieren, was mir nachher wirtschaftlich nicht weh tut?
Ich versuche mal zu sagen, einem konkreten Ausgedachten Beispiele nachzuholen, ob ich dich richtig verstanden habe. Also eine Bank hat Kunden und macht Online-Banking. Sie macht diese Online-Banking mit Open Source-Software. Investiert ihr aber nicht rein, weil die Open-Source-Software funktioniert halt so irgendwie, das passt schon. Dann gibt es ein Problem mit der Open Source-Software, das möglicherweise daraus entstanden ist, weil niemand mehr da rein investiert. Und die Bank sagt dann, oh ja, Online-Banking ist schiefgegangen, das tut uns jetzt echt leid, liebe Kunden, aber das ist euer Problem.
Ja, oder sie haben sogar noch mit dem Finger, wir haben ja hier ein konkretes Beispiel auf Open-SSL-Entwickler gezeigt, dann haben gesagt, diese acht Entwickler, die haben es verbockt. Aber die Bank hat kein einziges Mal einen Cent an die Entwicklung, die Wartung von dieser Software investiert.
Also jetzt sprichst du auf Heartbleed an. Also Sicherheitslücke aus dem letzten Jahr, die das HTTPS, was wir manchmal in unseren Web-Browsern sehen, halt kaputt gemacht hat, das kann man so einfach sagen.
Und da, als das rauskam, ist festgestellt worden, dass es eigentlich für die Verbreitung dieser Software sehr wenig Leute waren, die das Ganze entwickelt haben und das fast keine von den großen Unternehmen, die diese Software in so einem sicherheitskritischen Bereich verwendet, Geld investiert hat, damit die Software auch weiter gewartet wird.
Jetzt könnte man bei SSL sagen, naja gut, das ist tatsächlich so, das könnte man denen auch zum Vorwurf machen, zumindest den moralischen, dass man sagt, wenn ihr das schon benutzt und auch ja eigentlich mit der Sicherheit werbt, die das eurem Produkt verleiht, dann solltet ihr auch mal Geld rein investieren. Hat sich das denn jetzt geändert, bevor wir weitergehen? Ist da seit diesem Fehler was passiert?
Ja, also Hardplate ist ja so ein bisschen der Anstoß von der ganzen Debatte gewesen, wie finanziert man sicherheitskritische, freie Software? Und da gab es dann auch ein paar Unternehmen, die sich zusammengetan haben und Geld in den Topf geworfen haben und gesagt haben, aus dem Topf wollen wir dann Software wieder finanzieren, dass da Audits gemacht werden, dass da Entwickler bezahlt werden, dass sie das weiterentwickeln sollen. Das wollen wir aus dem Topf mitmachen. Das ist jetzt auch der Topf, aus dem auch ein Teil von der GnuPG-Entwicklung weiter mit bezahlt werden soll. Das ist gemacht worden. Wobei, wenn man sich die Beträge dort anschaut und sieht, was für Unternehmen da sind oder welche Unternehmen da auch nicht drin sind und wie viel Geld Unternehmen oft machen, die eigentlich auf unsere Daten aufpassen sollten, dann ist das Peanuts, von wem wir da gerade sprechen. Von daher, das ist ein Anstoß, der ein paar Unternehmen jetzt dazu gebracht hat, dass die Änderungen machen, dass die Geld investieren. Aber es sind sehr wenige Unternehmen, die sich daran im Moment noch beteiligen.
Darf ich da kurz einhaken, es ist nicht immer nur ein Problem des mangelnden Geldes. Wenn bestimmte Projekte sich schon strukturell in eine falsche Richtung entwickelt haben, wird es nicht viel besser, wenn man da Geld hinterher wirft. Das heißt, wenn es eh schon Projektmanagement-Probleme gibt, wie bei OpenSSL zum Beispiel auch lange gesehen. OpenSSL hatte das Problem, dass sie sich haben zertifizieren lassen und mit dieser Zertifizierung einen bestimmten Softwarestand immer wieder weiter verkauft haben an bestimmte Kunden innerhalb eines rechtlichen Konstrukts, den sie an dieses Projekt rangehangen haben. Und hatten am Ende wenig Interesse daran, bestimmte Dinge, die eigentlich moderne Bibliotheken noch mitbringen, sondern heutzutage defensive Programmierung, bestimmte Änderungen an der API einfach nicht mehr reingezogen haben. Sie haben sich aktiv gegen Kontributionen gewährt, die dazugegeben worden sind. Und das Problem kannst du nicht mit Geld lösen.
Naja, also so, wie du es gerade erzählt hast, kann man es schon mit Geld lösen, weil es wäre gar nicht dazu gekommen, wenn immer genug Geld da gewesen wäre, wenn sie es nicht in diesem Stand hätten verkaufen müssen.
Sie sind da ganz gut ausgekommen, erst mal mit ihrem Modell. Das Problem ist, wenn du ein Projekt hast, was irgendwie vor sich hin wurschtelt, dann gibt es immer die Option, ganz viel Geld hinzuwerfen, und zu sagen, wir machen einen Fork. Also wir entwickeln diese Bibliothek unabhängig von den Entwicklern weiter, die das gerade tun. Aber sowas kann man auch machen, ohne dass da Geld hingeworfen wird. Das Open-SSL ist auch wieder ein super Beispiel, weil die OpenBSD-Entwickler dann gesagt haben, wir haben dieses Open-SSL bei uns in einer Codebase, und wir wollen nicht, dass so hässliche Software da drin ist. Und haben dann gesagt, wir machen jetzt einen feindlichen Fork, haben diese Software dann unter dem Namen ReSSL erstmal von diversen alten Zöpfen befreit, haben dort Support für Software. Und das ist alles, ohne dass man Geld investiert, ist das schon passiert. Also es ist ein mehrdimensionales Problem. Man kann sowas mit Geld erschlagen, aber zuweilen muss man das dann auch ohne das Original-Team machen.
Aber es ist nochmal übergeordnet, nehmen wir uns eine Versicherung, die muss sicherstellen, dass unsere Daten zum Beispiel nicht geleakt werden, dass sie nicht rauskommen, dass sie das System nicht verlassen, sondern dass sie dort sicher verwahrt sind. Und wenn es diesem Unternehmen, dieser Versicherung, sehr stark wehtun würde, wirtschaftlich, wenn unsere Daten rausgehen, wenn das eigene System unsicher ist, dann würden die auch mehr Aufwand betreiben, um zu schauen, ist das denn eine Bibliothek, die jetzt mal angenommen unsicher ist und selbst wenn man da mehr Geld drauf wirft, dann wird die nicht sicherer. Dann müssen sie sich trotzdem nach Alternativen umschauen, weil sie haben sehr viel Umsatz, sie haben eine Verantwortung dafür, dass sie das System eigentlich sicher halten. Aber es ist kein wirtschaftlicher Anreiz da, das wirklich umzusetzen. Und das ist meiner Ansicht nach eins von den größten Problemen, dass die Leute, die eigentlich dafür sorgen müssen, also die die Möglichkeit haben, ein System sicher zu machen, nicht die Leute sind, die nachher den Schaden haben, wenn ein System wirklich unsicher ist.
Aber siehst du da quasi den Gesetzgeber in der Pflicht? Oder wie sollte man sowas etablieren?
Also eine Möglichkeit wäre, das gesetzlich zu machen. Es gibt bestimmt auch andere Möglichkeiten. Ich meine, das ist eine Sache, die wir uns jetzt mehr darüber Gedanken machen müssen. Aber ich denke, am wichtigsten ist erst mal, dass man sich bewusst darüber ist, die Leute, die ein System sicherer machen können, sind meistens nicht die, die darunter leiden, wenn es unsicher ist im Moment.
Ich glaube, es ist primär auch jetzt kein Problem, was die Politik lösen muss. Alleine wird sie auch gar nicht können, sondern eher mal wieder ein gesellschaftliches Problem, wo es halt auf der einen Seite Leute gibt, die nur nehmen, und irgendwann sogar eine Entwartungshaltung an Open Source-Projekte entwickeln, im Sinne von, warum habt ihr nicht Funktionalität XY? Macht mal, aber bis morgen und umsonst natürlich, wo so eine kostenlose Kultur dann vorherrscht.
Und es muss auch nicht immer Geld sein.
Also ein Dankeschön oder, wie Erdgeist Freund so schön sagte, mal ein Bier vorbeischecken, das ist oftmals, das motiviert dann viel mehr als die 10 Euro, weil man weiß dann wieder, für wen macht man den ganzen Mist hier.
Na ja gut, aber das Skaliert natürlich auch nicht unendlich. Und wir reden ja heute tatsächlich darüber, wie so eine Projekte finanziert werden können, nicht wie sie sich betrinken können.
Wir haben zusammen. Aber auf der anderen Seite können wir das Ganze auch vom anderen Ende der Skala, nämlich vom Privatnutzer sehen. Wir haben beispielsweise bei OnCloud halt auch für mobile Betriebssysteme Apps in den jeweiligen App-Stores. Die lassen sich halt auch selber im Quellcode kompilieren. Überhaupt kein Thema, jeder kann das. Das ist natürlich praktisch etwas anders. Da haben wir uns dafür entschieden, zu sagen, wer sich das jetzt aus dem App-Store runterlädt. Gerade für Apple gibt es da ja wenig Alternativen zum offiziellen App-Store. Es kostet halt irgendwie 99 Cent, Euro 50. Also nichts, was man nicht für einen Cappuccino morgens auch ausgeben würde oder Nespresso. Und es kommen dann tatsächlich Leute zu uns und sagen, warum muss ich da jetzt Geld für zahlen? Und unsere Argumentation ist immer, wir brauchen auch jemanden, der diese Applikation weiterentwickelt und der möchte gerne auch irgendwie sein Cappuccino kaufen. Und so schließt sich der Kreis. Und das trifft auf komplettes Unverständnis. Also das ist sowohl auf der oberen Ebene mit den Unternehmen, die sagen, wir haben doch diese Bibliothek, die ist doch schön und warum sollten wir? Aber das trifft genauso gut den kleinen Privatanwender, der da wirklich eine sehr einfache, also die App-Stores mögen ja verteufelt werden, wie sie wollen, aber es ist eine sehr einfache Art und Weise einfach demjenigen, der den Programm schreibt, eine kleine Summe zukommen zu lassen. Und dann ist das halt auch wieder zu viel, weil könnte ja auch umsonst sein. Und so trifft es quasi jeden, der da dran mitwirken könnte.
So und jetzt noch mal zurück zu GnuPG. Eine Software, die ja sozusagen tatsächlich eher, also in meinem Kenntnisstand zumindest korrigiert mich, wenn es noch eine andere Anwendungsmöglichkeit gibt, die erstmal von Einzel-Usern benutzt wird, die halt miteinander verschlüsselt kommunizieren wollen. Und die halt tatsächlich auch deutlich mehr.
Also viel von dem Signieren von Software, die du automatisiert runterlädst, passiert über GnuPG. Das heißt, wenn du von irgendeinem Entwickler Software runterlädst und vergleichen möchtest, ob das vom selben Typen digital signiert worden ist, wie als ich das erste Mal die Software installiert habe.
Alle LILU-Distributionen sichern ihre Updates und ihre Softwarepakete über GnuPG ab. Das läuft im Hintergrund, das kriegst du gar nicht mit.
Dann darfst du vielleicht noch mal kurz erklären. Also wenn man ein Update für ein Programm runterlädt, dann lädt man nicht nur einfach die Datei runter, sondern es wird im Hintergrund sozusagen eine verschlüsselte Datei runter oder eine signierte.
Man kann das ganz gut vergleichen mit einer Blombe. Also wenn du eine Software bei dir auf dem Computer installieren willst, dann willst du die Software von dem Entwickler und nicht die von der NSA. Und der Entwickler benutzt GnuPG, um das Ganze zu signieren. Also wie wenn man jetzt so einen Kasten nimmt, dann macht man eine Blombe hin. Und wenn das dann bei mir ankommt, das Paket, dann schaue ich mir das an und prüfe die Signatur und schaue, ist die Blombe noch zu oder hat die schon jemand aufgemacht und dadurch eventuell Änderungen an der Software gemacht.
So, das heißt, es gibt also nicht nur die End-User, die ihre Mails verschütteln, sondern es gibt auch noch Firmen, die ein Interesse haben. Woran ist das denn schief gegangen mit der Finanzierung?
Du sagst, schief gegangen mit der Finanzierung. Also erstmal ist natürlich dieser Zeitungsartikel auch ein wenig sehr Tränendrüse und war glaube ich dem Werner Koch auch unangenehm im Nachhinein, dass das so aufgebrauscht worden ist. Dieses Crowdfunding, was er da ursprünglich angeleitet hat, lief ja schon eine Weile und war jetzt auch nicht unbedingt so, dass er ganz dringend jetzt den Lebensunterhalt davon verdienen wollte. Er hat nur gemeint, wenn er jetzt noch mehr Zeit rein investieren will.
Das habe ich ja, als hätte ich Matthias sozusagen schüttelt auf dem Kopf.
Also vielleicht mal kurz die Historie. Also Werner hat damals noch, als das Gnu-Projekt gestartet ist, gab es mal die Überlegung noch, als hat Gnu-Projekt gemeint, wir brauchen noch seine Verschlüsselungssoftware. Und Werner hat sich das angeguckt und hat gedacht, okay, das könnte ich machen. Und hat am Anfang das als Hobbyprojekt mit angefangen. Dann ist das Ganze ein bisschen gewachsen und er hat dann ein Unternehmen gegründet und hat damit Aufträge angenommen, um eben Änderungen zu machen, die andere Leute hatten Wünsche an die Software. Es kam dann auch später dazu noch, dass manche von den Aufträgen, zum Beispiel gerade auch hier von deutschen Ministerien mit kamen, da kam was vom Wirtschaftsministerium, die hatten eine Zeit bestimmte Wünsche an GnuPG. Es gab auch eine Portierung von GnuPG, dass das auch auf Windows funktioniert und da gab es Aufträge für. Da gab es Geld und Werner hat da mit dran gearbeitet, andere Unternehmen haben da auch mit dran gearbeitet. Das war auch jetzt nicht eine Sache, dass nur G10 Co. dass das Unternehmen von Werner an GnuPG entwickelt hat, sondern da waren andere mit drin und haben so Aufträge mit angenommen. Jetzt ist es so gewesen, dass eben das, was wir vorher mit besprochen hatten, wenn jetzt immer mehr Interessen kommen, dann wird sowas komplexer. Da ist jetzt eine Ministerium, die sagt, wir hätten das gerne auf Windows, das andere sagt, aber wir wollen, dass das mit der Software mit funktioniert, wir hätten doch die Funktionalität gerne drin und dann ist das Ganze komplexer geworden. Und wenn man so Funktionen schreibt, dann hat man meistens nicht die Zeit, auch die Wartung zu machen. Jetzt ein anderes Problem, was man teilweise bei so freien Softwareprogrammierung hat oder generell bei Softwareentwicklung hat, ist, Leute, die gut Software schreiben, gute Hacker, sind nicht immer gute Marketingleute, sind nicht immer gute Geschäftsleute. Das heißt, die hacken gerne und lösen gerne ein technisches Problem. Jetzt hat der Werner oft, wenn er hat geschaut, dass er GnuPG-Entwicklung weitermacht und nicht jetzt jemand dafür bezahlt, dass der jetzt tolle Werbebroschüren macht, das den Leuten gibt, damit die wieder Geld geben, damit man weiter finanzieren kann. Und da ist eben auch viel Idealismus drin, dass man braucht Verschlüsselungssoftware und ich entwickle daran. Jetzt gab es eben dann das Problem, dass nicht mehr neue Aufträge reingekommen sind, in dem Umfang, dass man das weiter mehrere Leute davon bezahlen kann. Also eine Zeit lang, als es die Aufträge gab, war G10 Code. Da gab es dann noch einen zweiten Entwickler zum Beispiel, der dafür bezahlt worden ist. Oder auch andere Unternehmen, die da mitgemacht hatten. Und als es dann weggebrochen ist, gab es keine neuen Projekte. Nur ein paar kleinere Sachen, mit denen man sich über Wasser gehalten hat. Und dann war halt Werner irgendwann in der Situation, mache ich so weiter mit dem Einkommen? Kann ich da mit einer Familie finanzieren? Jetzt musste ich schon einen Entwickler entlassen. Wie mache ich weiter? Und eine Überlegung war eben, kann man das vielleicht durch Spenden mitmachen? Die Jahre davor kamen so 5.000 Euro im Jahr zusammen durch GnuPG-Spenden. Dann gab es eine Crowdfunding-Kampagne, da kamen dann 35.000 Euro, glaube ich. Da kamen das Problem mit dazu, dass Crowdfunding, da kommt nicht 35.000 Euro bei Werner Koch für die GnuPG-Entwicklung an, sondern da geht die Plattformgebühr weg für die Crowdfunding-Plattform, da gehen Steuern ab. Und wenn das dann weg ist, dann hast du teilweise noch die Hälfte davon. Und für 15.000 Euro, wie lange kannst du da entwickeln? Kannst du nicht einen Jahresgehalt von einem Entwickler bezahlen?
Soll vorkommen.
Soll vorkommen, sollte aber nicht vorkommen. Und was dann gewesen ist, ist, dass man noch mal einen Spendenaufruf gemacht hatte, der ist dann hier von Warholen Stiftung, FSFE, hat das auch mit verbreitet gehabt, dann ist das auch auf Boing Boing erschienen, da kam dann auch mal was zusammen, das waren dann bis Ende Januar 40.000 Euro kamen da zusammen, seit letztem Dezember. Das war schon mal achtmal so viel, wie sonst im Jahr zusammengekommen sind. Aber wenn man zwei Entwickler bezahlen will, eine Firma unterhalten will, dann sind so 120.000 eher so ein Ziel, was man so verfolgen sollte. Und das ist schon nicht unbedingt der Bestbezahl des Programmierers, wenn man 120.000 Euro zwei Leute von bezahlen will. Jetzt gab es dann eben einen großen Artikel oder einen Artikel, der eine große Auswirkung hatte. Das war ein Artikel auf ProPublica. Der war relativ emotional auch geschrieben, hat so ein bisschen die persönliche Geschichte erzählt, hat da auch manche Sachen vielleicht ein bisschen vereinfacht dargestellt, was, wie hier Erdgeist gerade meinte, Werner auch nachher nicht ganz so angenehm alles war. Aber was das auf jeden Fall gebracht hatte, war, dass das war, nachdem der Artikel erschienen ist, ist innerhalb von 24 Stunden sind 120.000 Euro zusätzlich reingekommen. Mittlerweile, ich habe gerade vorher noch mal geguckt, dass auf der GnuPG-Spendenseite sind 222.000 Euro irgendwas zusammengekommen. Dazu hat die Linux Foundation gesagt, dass sie 60.000 Euro für einen zusätzlichen Entwickler bezahlen wollen, weil sie gemerkt haben, GnuPG ist so unterfinanziert, wir wollen kein zweites Heartbleed, also der Bug, der da letztes Jahr rauskam. Dazu kamen dann Facebook, die gesagt haben, wir wollen 50.000 Dollar spenden. Dann gab es Stripe, die gesagt haben, sie wollen 50.000 Spenden. Und Bauholland hat auch noch Spenden angenommen, die sind auch noch ungefähr 10.000 Euro. Also das ist auf einmal dann zusammengekommen.
Also wir sehen jetzt ja genau das. Dann, wenn der Fokus der Öffentlichkeit drauf fällt, sei es die SSL-Nummer oder jetzt GnuPG, dann lässt sich das auf einmal finanzieren. Aber es ist halt immer Brände löschen. Und es ist genau. Es ist nicht sich mal hinsetzen, sich überlegen, was ist kritische Infrastruktur, die wir in Open Source auch haben wollen. Als Europäer, gerade jetzt mit den ganzen NSL-Geschichten die letzten paar Jahre, will man nicht vielleicht mal eine europäische Open Source Textverarbeitung haben?
Plus an der Stelle muss man auch, wenn die Community jetzt Geld hingegeben hat für den Projektstand, so wie er ist, dieses GnuPG, in dem Zustand, wie es ist. Und es gibt für mich ein bisschen das Problem, es gibt keine Qualitätskontrolle. Da hast du jetzt Geld und wir belohnen dich mal. Wir haben gar nicht reingeguckt, wie die Software gerade aussieht. Und es gibt irgendwie auch nicht wirklich negative Auswirkungen, wenn er ab jetzt das Projekt verkackt. Also es gibt kein übergeordnetes Projektmanagement, was da mal draufguckt. Und in der Vergangenheit hat sich irgendwie bei GnuPG und auch bei OpenSSL gezeigt, dass dort strukturelle Probleme... Für mich ist es ein strukturelles Problem, wenn irgendjemand versucht, eine Firma drumherum aufzumachen mit umklarem Ausgang. Wenn er nicht schon vorfällt, lange genug plant, um zu gucken, wie lange kann ich davon leben und im Zweifel noch irgendwie einen Back-up-Plan haben, dass ich dann nicht irgendwie verarmt dastehe. Wenn man das nicht tut, dann ist es für mich naiv. Und wenn man am Ende das Projekt noch halt mit Geisel nimmt, wie die OpenSSL zum Beispiel, dann ist das für mich unverantwortlich. Also man muss immer schon schauen, dass man nicht Hunger hat. Und man kann nicht am Ende dann sagen, hier ist der Deal, ich mach mal für alles kostenlos, ich lasse mich von Leuten bezahlen für Sonder-Spezial-Features und irgendwann ankommen und sagen, oh jetzt ist mein Geld jetzt alle wirklich so fett zugrunde.
Was du da sagst ist, wenn du Open Source-Entwickler sein willst, dann musst du gefälligst fit genug sein, dir auch noch einen Zweitstopp auf die Beine zu stellen und das Marketing zu machen.
Nein, das ist nicht was ich sage. Man muss im Zweifel das Beveilen, ein Projekt betrachten, für die nächsten fünf Jahre habe ich hier einen Job, weil die Finanzierung ist gesichert, das mache ich als Selbstständiger auch. Ich habe irgendeinen Kunden für die nächsten fünf Jahre und dann ist gut. Aber danach muss ich halt wieder schauen, entweder geht das Projekt weiter oder ich mache etwas anderes und sich einfach so in Abhängigkeit von so einem Projekt zu begeben, ist grundgefährlich und wenn es auch nur kritische Infrastruktur ist, dann ist es für mich verantwortungslos.
Also für mich hat das Ganze mit GnuPG eine Sache ganz extrem gezeigt, das war, dass viele Menschen die Software benutzt haben, ohne sich Gedanken darüber zu machen, wie das dann finanziert ist.
So weit noch, ohne es zu wissen.
Ja, teilweise ohne zu wissen, dass sie die Software überhaupt drin haben. Das ist ja noch fahrlässiger. Da haben große Unternehmen, die brauchen diese Software, um sicherzustellen, dass sie die richtigen Pakete installieren oder andere Verschlüsselungstätigkeiten damit zu machen, Daten zu verschlüsseln und wissen nicht mal, dass sie davon abhängig sind. Jetzt haben sie auf einmal durch den Artikel mitgemerkt, da ist eine Software, die haben wir bei uns auch drin. Das ist ja vor uns ganz wichtig. Da kann es jetzt sein, dass der das nicht mehr weitermacht. Dann merkt man auf einmal, dass das, was ich die ganze Zeit kostenlos genommen habe, was ich für, ich atme mal Luft ein, ist die ganze Zeit da. Das sollte ich vielleicht was für bezahlen. Das war für mich die eine Lehre, die ich daraus gezogen habe, dass viele Unternehmen und auch viele Privatpersonen Software einfach nutzen, ohne sich Gedanken zu machen, wie die eigentlich entsteht. Der zweite Punkt war, was du gemeint hast, dass du erwartest, dass wenn jemand freie Software schreibt, dass der auch ein guter Geschäftsmann ist. Das ist eben der Punkt, den ich gemeint habe. Es gibt Entwickler, die sind nicht so die...
Ich glaube, darf ich das mal ganz kurz erklären?
Entschuldigt, Leute, aber jetzt wird gerade ein bisschen langer. Matthias, sag doch mal bitte zu Ende.
Also es gibt Entwickler, die sind nicht so die guten Geschäftsleute. Das sind Leute, die wollen einfach gute Software schreiben. Jetzt ist es aber so, dass es halt oft nicht so funktioniert, weil teilweise, wenn ich extrem gutes Marketing habe, aber eine schlechte Software, dann verdiene ich teilweise mehr Geld, wie wenn ich gute Software schreibe, aber kein Marketing mache.
Und das sind ja nicht die einzigen Achsen. Du hast ja Projektmanagement, du hast viele andere Dinge, die dann noch mit reinspielen, die du als einfacher, in meinem Keller entwickler halt, wie auch dann grundsätzlich falsch machst. Und ich denke eher, dass wenn so eine Foundation Geld einsammelt, dann sollte sie, genauso wie sie Programmierer dahinstellt, Leute mit Projektmanagement-Erfahrung einfach auch mitbezahlen. Sagen, dieses Projekt brauchte offensichtlich Hilfe, struktureller Natur, und ich muss am Ende auch den Daumen drauf haben, wenn ich einen Programmierer bezahle, dass ich dem immer noch sagen kann, nee, so geht das nicht, und im Zweifel bist du gefeuert. Und genau diese Keule muss man auch haben und nicht einfach un-gesehen Geld dahinter werfen. Und das ist, glaube ich, der unterschätzte Faktor, dass einfach nur un-gesehenen Spenden einsammeln und sagen, okay, hier nimm mal, macht die Software nicht besser, sondern muss dann auch in dem Moment, wo die Community Geld einsammelt und in die Richtung Projekt wirft, dafür sorgen, dass dieses Geld verantwortungsbewusst eingesetzt wird.
Also dann habe ich jetzt zu sagen, nachdem es nach einer Stunde Sendung ganz gut aussah, sieht es nach einer halben Stunde Sendung wieder ganz bitter aus, nämlich entweder es kommt nur das Geld von großen Firmen oder es kommt von der Community, aber es ist dann irgendwie auch nicht richtig. Wir werden die letzte halbe Stunde dann gleich mal nutzen, um vielleicht ein zumindest potenziell tragfähiges Modell für Open-Source-Software-Finanzierung zu entwerfen. Vorher noch eine kleine Musik, die auch eingesandt wurde, aufgrund des Wunsches eine neue Openermusik fürs Chaos-Radio vielleicht zu haben. Die kommt von Tobias Sensing und er hat hier keinen Namen gegeben, aber wir hören mal kurz rein. So, letzte halbe Stunde im Chaos-Radio 209 über Open-Source-Finanzierung in der Marienstrasse 11. Falls ihr jetzt auch schnell vorbeikommen wollt, könnt ihr es gerne machen, hier in Berlin Erdgeistin da, Lasse, Matthias Kirschner von der FSFE. Yes, fehlerfrei gesagt und Danimo. Und es geht heute abends so ein bisschen hin und her. Also während es sich am Anfang der Sendung einhatte so, ja, mit der Open-Source-Finanzierung ist jetzt nicht so ein großes Problem, weil da gibt es immer Firmen, die irgendwie Geld reinwerfen. Da hatten wir dann festgestellt, naja, es gibt doch so ein kleines Problem, weil halt so Projekte wie OpenSSL und GnuPG haben halt nicht so viel Geld und werden dann immer so gelöscht mit großen Haufen, die dann über ihn ausgekippt werden, wenn es mal dringend wird. Aber dann ist auch das nicht ganz unproblematisch, meint der Erdgeist zumindest dann, weil dann, sagen große Batzen Geld, irgendwo hingeworfen werden, wo man dann gar nicht mehr so genau weiß, ist das dann alles eine Richtigkeit. Was braucht es denn in Zukunft? Vielleicht schaffen wir das in einer halben Stunde noch mal eben die Welt zu retten. Um Open Source-Software nicht nur nachhaltig zu finanzieren, sondern dann auch dafür zu sorgen, dass diese Finanzierung sinnvoll angewendet wird.
Eine Art Zwischeninstanz eigentlich. So was wie die Free Software Foundation, dass man lieber der, der das Geld zum Beispiel jetzt gibt, und die dann dafür gerade stehen, dass so etwas wie eine sichere E-Mail-Verschlüsselung entwickelt wird. Ob sie das Geld dann an GnuPG zum Schluss geben und es dort entwickelt wird, das steht ja auf einer ganz anderen Karte. Einfach ist nicht projektgebunden wegzugeben, sondern wirklich eher eine Agenda haben, was wollen wir als Open Source-Software vorliegen haben. Und dann ist so etwas wie die Open Source Foundation dazu da, dass das nach und nach schrittweise umgesetzt wird.
Eigentlich wäre auch so was noch mal eine Idee für einen Staat, dass der dahergeht und sagt, wir meinen das jetzt mal ernst, wir gucken, welche Komponenten sind denn gerade kritisch, was können wir machen, was kostet uns das. Und dann kann man auch ein bisschen kompetitiv vielleicht mal ausschreiben, sagen, schickt mal ein paar Lösungen ein. Grundvoraussetzungen sind, ihr werdet bezahlt, aber danach ist es irgendwie Open Source, wie unter einer Lizenz, die wir ansagen, und darf jeder benutzen. Und derjenige, der im besten Stück Software in einem unabhängigen Ordet von vielleicht noch anderen Leuten, die sich da bewerben, gewinnt, der bekommt noch einen Bonus dazu und den nächsten Auftrag auch noch.
Und die Hintertür gibt es umsonst dazu.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, so einen Start, sich kritische Software entwickeln zu lassen, ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher.
Nicht den Start entwickeln lassen. Du kannst einfach einen Auftrag geben, dass so unterschiedliche Buden das machen. Und dann, es gibt da Mittel und Wege, dort einfach wenig Geld. Es reicht dann wenig Geld für abgeschlossene Projekte, die vorher klar definiert werden. Und wenn es Open Source ist, kann natürlich jeder reingucken. Wie willst du das Hintertür reingucken?
Also darüber möchte ich dann gleich noch mal vielleicht in 10 Minuten sprechen, da muss man immer reingucken. Das muss halt auch jemand machen. Das ist ja noch mal ein zweites Problem. Aber gibt es noch andere Vorschläge zur nachhaltigen Finanzierung?
Also für mich ist das ein mehrschichtiges Modell. Das eine ist, es gibt die Möglichkeit, dass man Organisationen hat, an denen man das bündelt, wie zum Beispiel irgendwelchen Stiftungen, Vereine, an die man Geld geben kann als Privatperson oder auch an die Unternehmen Geld geben können, die dann das Geld wieder verteilen und die dann auch dafür sorgen, dass bestimmte Interessen durchgesetzt werden. Das haben wir ja auch schon in freier Software, haben wir solche Stiftungen und Vereine. Wir haben zum Beispiel die Free Software Foundation in den USA, die macht viel freie Softwareentwicklung mit dem Gnu-Projekt und hat da eine Agenda, macht ein Projektmanagement und setzt dort ihre Interessen mit durch. Und wenn man da Geld gibt, dann weiß man, okay, das geht in den Zielen lang. Da gibt es in Deutschland, da haben wir zum Beispiel auch so etwas wie KDE-EV, was Daniel ja auch mit hier kennt. Und da kann man auch Geld mit hinbezahlen und die fördern sowas auch. Das ist aber nur ein Aspekt. Der andere ist eben, dass Unternehmen auch selbst, wenn sie bestimmte Interessen haben, dafür bezahlen müssen, dass diese Software mitentwickelt wird. Und da finde ich, das ist einer von den Aspekten, die eben lange Zeit überhaupt nicht berücksichtigt worden ist. Die Unternehmen haben sich nicht angeguckt, was für Software habe ich, was für Software bräuchte ich und wie investiere ich die. Wir haben die nächste Schicht, das ist der Staat. Der Staat hat auch eine Infrastruktur und hat meiner Ansicht nach eine Verantwortung, dass er diese Infrastruktur sicher hält, dass er die wartet und dafür muss er auch Geld bezahlen. Ich will aber eigentlich nicht, dass eine von denen die alleinige Lösung ist, mit der wir das machen. Ich will nicht, dass es nur Unternehmen sind. Ich will nicht, dass es nur Stiftungen und andere Non-Profit sind. Ich will nicht, dass es nur der Staat ist. Ich will, dass alle Leute gemeinsam das lösen. Das ist unsere Infrastruktur, an der wir gemeinsam entwickeln müssen.
Nein, oder auch gegeneinander, auch gesunde Konkurrenz einfach fördern.
Genau, genau. Deswegen fände ich auch so Vorschläge, mich ehrt das, wenn jemand sagt, die FSFE soll das machen und wir wollen der FSFE Geld geben und spenden und die soll das dann machen. Aber das ist eigentlich eine Aufgabe, die ich gar nicht haben will als FSFE. Das ist etwas, ich will nicht entscheiden, was ist denn jetzt gerade das Wichtigste in Freier Software? Ich will, dass mehrere Leute das entscheiden, dass Privatleute sagen, das ist ein nettes Projekt, denen gebe ich Geld, da will ich mal schauen, was da passiert, da investiere ich mal was rein. Und bei manchen Projekten ist das ja auch für Privatsoftware, da sind das eben die 5 Euro für die App, die auch mal mit entscheiden, ob eine Software weiterentwickelt wird oder nicht, wenn das entsprechend Leute machen. Und genauso ist es dann eben für Unternehmen, da sind das halt andere Beträge, da sind das halt eher, wir geben 10.000 Euro und bezahlen das, die anderen bezahlen halt 100.000 Euro und dann wird sowas mitgemacht. Aber es muss von vielen Leuten gemacht werden und wir müssen schauen, dass wir konkurrierende Lösungen auch haben, wo wir einfach gucken, was wird denn besser? Was ist denn der bessere Ansatz?
Der Staat gibt ja eh gerade raue Mengen Geld für Close Source. Guck dir den Staat, Strojaner. Wurde für den Staat entwickelt, was für ein Schrott da rausgekommen ist, hast du dann gesehen. Also dort gibt es auch Optimierungspotenzial, wo ich irgendwie mal sagen würde, dass man das mit einem Schwung mal angehen kann.
Okay, ich zusammengefasst, also Erdgeissprecher des CCC fordert Open Source-Finanzierung des neuen Strojaners.
Nein, eher andersrum. Lieber in Open Source als in Close Source-Projekte, die dann verkackt werden.
Es ist also kurz zusammengefasst, das ist auch unsere Forderung, dass öffentlich finanzierte Software, Software, die von öffentlichem Geld finanziert wird, die muss freie Software sein. Alles, was neu entwickelt wird, muss als freies Software veröffentlicht werden. Weil dann haben andere Unternehmen auch die Möglichkeit, auf Basis davon wieder andere Lösungen zu entwickeln, Forks zu machen, konkurrieren gegen das eine Unternehmen, was vielleicht am Anfang den Auftrag gegeben hat. Und das ist was, was durchweg eigentlich von der Verantwortung von dem Staat ist, dass Software, die mit Steuergeld finanziert worden ist, auch in der Forschung, ob das die App ist, die das Ministerium macht oder eben irgendwelche neuen Aufträge für Sonderanfällung, das muss als freie Software veröffentlicht werden.
Und würde auch nochmal ganz anders Vertrauen geben in so Software, die zum Beispiel im Zensus eingesetzt wurde, weil man in dem Moment auch wirklich gucken könnte, was macht die Software und all diese Verdächtigungen, die überwachen uns und man weiß es halt nicht, wenn man nicht reingucken kann.
Ja, aber das ist ja sozusagen jetzt noch ein Thema, was dann immer noch ansteht, diese Open Source-Software, da kann ja jeder reingucken, das wird ja nicht gemacht, da war ja Hardbit auch ein sehr schönes Beispiel dafür.
Aber das ist dann irgendwie eine Frage wirklich, das Geld ist, weil Audits sind öde. Also Audits ist meistens ziemlich schwer, Leute dazu zu bekommen, sich fremder Leute wohlriechenden Code anzugucken und Anmerkungen zu machen. Das ist echt deutlich schwieriger, Leute dazu zu bekommen, als mal eben irgendwas dazu zu geben, was man leichter sieht. Also eine Übersetzung oder ein nettes Logo machen oder eine Grafik oder ein bisschen Code dazu führen. Leute sind immer mehr so, lieber was Neues schaffen, als irgendwie all das zu maintainen. Ich glaube, in die Maintenance und Audits punktuell mehr Geld reinzustecken, als in die Weiterentwicklung, wäre für mich der richtige Ansatz.
Aber wo wir gerade von diesem gesunden Wettbewerb von verschiedenen Entitäten, die halt Geld haben, reden, dann wäre es doch zum Beispiel die Zielsetzung einer Stiftung zu sagen, okay, der Staat hat jetzt eine Software, die Open Source dann wäre, die jetzt irgendwie ein Zensus oder irgendeine kritische Infrastruktur ist, na die ist Open Source, dann gucken wir uns die doch mal an. Das ist unsere Aufgabe als Foundation, die wir jetzt mal wegen den Staat überwachen. Solche Organisationen gibt es ja bereits und das würde man dann halt nur auf technischer Ebene tun. Und wir zertifizieren jeden Mist, wie weit mein Monitor von meinem Schreibtisch wegsteht, wie weit die Tastatur, überall gibt es DIN und ISO-Normen, warum eben nicht dann auch für Software und es darf halt dann auf staatlicher Seite nur Software eingesetzt werden, die mindestens von zwei unabhängigen Parteien auditiert wurde zum Beispiel oder was auch immer.
Na oder man schickt irgendwie mal Studenten dahin, also es gibt halt blöderweise diese Freiheit der Forschung an den Universitäten, aber man könnte ja einfach mal einen verpflichtenden Uni-Schein machen für du musst mindestens ein Open Source Projekt so nach allen Regeln der Kunst auditiert haben und dafür gibst du dann ein Schein und ohne das kriegst du dein Studium nicht.
Allerdings muss man auch sagen, sehr viele Unis, die wirklich Reputationen haben in Sachen Software-Sicherheit Leute auszubilden, machen das ja schon als Hausaufgabe. Also das ist ja nicht und das ist nur zu selten, aber es ist durchaus etwas, was einem als Uni Vorteile bringen kann.
Ich würde irgendwie auch weitergehen bei Gestaltungshochschulen oder Kunsthochschulen sagen, so mindestens ein Open Source-Projekt mal im UI begleiten, die schlimmsten Scharten auszuwetzen und zu sagen, du brauchst einen Pflichtschein für schnapp dir irgendein Goethe-Tool Open Source und schreib den Entwicklern oder entwickel ein Logo und schreib den Entwicklern, was sie falsch gemacht haben.
Geisteswissenschaftler können Doku schreiben, Quellcode, Kommentare anpassen.
Das ist ja eine schöne Idee, aber für wie wahrscheinlich haltet ihr das?
Null.
Steht da tropf, na klar. Dass das geht, einfach weiter ningeln, na gut. Also die Hochschulprofessoren sind zuweilen ein wenig eigen und in den ganzen Kommissionen, die das beschließen könnten, sitzen auch eher Geisteswissenschaftler als Informatiker. Ich sag steht da tropf, nöhlt den Stein, wenn die Leute groß geworden sind mit Open-Source-Software, werden sie vielleicht in der nächsten Generation das einsehen haben?
Ich finde, das sind alles schöne Ideen, dass man das macht an Universitäten. Ich glaube, was man sich bewusst sein muss, der Effekt wirklich, dass man jetzt eine Software, die man von Studenten auditieren lässt, dass die jetzt dadurch sicherer wird, da bin ich mir nicht sicher, ob das funktioniert. Also Software auditieren ist jetzt auch nicht ganz so einfach. Da braucht man ja auch Erfahrung, damit man das gut machen kann. Und da weiß ich nicht genau, wie da der Effekt ist. Aber ich denke trotzdem, dass das sowas eine sehr gute Idee ist, weil wenn Studenten sowas lernen, wie man andere Software auditiert, dann lernt man viel. Da lernt man erst mal, dass man selber gute Dokumentation für seinen Quellquot schreibt, dass man selber sauber programmiert. Da lernt man auch, dass Sicherheit ein Faktor ist, den man berücksichtigen sollte, wenn man Software schreibt. Und ich glaube, der Effekt ist noch mal viel, viel größer als der Effekt, bringt das wirklich der Software, was die da jetzt in dem Projekt mit angeguckt haben.
Und du setzt natürlich das Basislevel hoch. Also es gibt ja sehr viele Software, die nicht einmal einem Erstsemestler, der wirklich determiniert ist, da mal dran zu gehen, standhält. Und da setzt man ja erstmal ein ganz neues Basislevel, also dessen muss man sich halt auch klar sein.
Wobei es trotzdem zu unserer Frage, wie finanzieren wir freie Software, ist es halt ein Aspekt, dass man sagen kann, okay, wir ermutigen Studenten dazu, dass die solche Projekte mitmachen und verbessern dadurch die Qualität in Zukunft von unserer freien Software.
Wir können ja die Frage ein bisschen größer machen, wie finanziert man das hin, wie unterstützt man das, ohne immer Geld in die Hand nehmen zu müssen?
Na ja, Finanzierung sozusagen schon im Sinne von möglich machen und ich kann mir vorstellen, dass sozusagen, das hört sich zumindest jetzt auch gerade so an, dass die, wenn über Open-Source-Software gesprochen wird, dass es tatsächlich bei der Produktion meistens endet. Also die, also ich stelle es mir so vor, sobald es funktioniert, guckt dann keiner mehr so richtig drauf, also in die tieferen Ebenen und Eingeweide machen.
Genau, also unser Produkt ist seit 2001 am Start, ohne ausführliche Tests, verschiedenste Art von Testing, würde es das schon lange nicht mehr geben.
Na ja klar, aber der ganze Lebenszyklus drum rum, den du hast, der ist riesig.
So und ich will, also genau eigentlich geht es mehr darum, gar nicht die eine Quelle jetzt zu benennen und so muss es funktionieren, sondern genau ein Kulturproblem ist. Es muss von allen Seiten was passieren und wenn meine Firma seit Jahrzehnten Geld damit verdient, in Webprojekte zu machen, wo immer ein Apache-Webserver eingesetzt wird, dann kann man auch mal irgendwann, wenn man damit seine Millionen verdient hat, ein bisschen was zurückgeben, muss auch nicht immer Geld sein, kann auch Alkohol sein.
Und ich finde, es ist nicht nur, ich kann was zurückgeben, sondern ich finde, wir müssen die dazu bringen, dass sie das wirklich machen müssen. Also dass sie das einfach, dass die wirtschaftlichen Anreize so sind, dass sie das machen müssen. Dass wenn die ihre Daten verlieren, oder wenn die ihre Daten, also unsere Daten verlieren, dass es nicht uns mehr wehtut als denen.
Ich sehe, dass es noch ein Problem, wirklich was ich mit Kulturproblemen meine, ist, dass es auch sozial innerhalb der Communities gut ablaufen muss. Also man sieht die Linux-Community ist ja oft in der Kritik, dass dort ein sehr harscher Umgangston herrscht, der vielleicht auch bestimmte potenzielle Mithelfer mit bestimmten Skillsets auch abschreckt und das sieht man in vielen anderen Projekten, wo eben verschrobene Charaktere zusammenkommen, funktioniert es schlechter als in anderen Projekten, wo vielleicht die Community offenherziger ist und wo dann nicht die allerbesten Leute da mitmachen, aber irgendwie auch die Masse es da am Ende macht, dann viele Augen, wo wirklich dann viele Augen auf den Code gucken, die zwar alle nicht die allerbesten sind, aber in der Summe dann auch schon ein cooles Ergebnis abliefern.
Aber wie soll so ein Kulturwandel dann vonstatten gehen, also wodurch kann der ausgelöst werden?
Indem man das vorlebt, wie coole Communities funktionieren. Das ist natürlich auch mal entspannter, in schönen Communities sich zu treffen, zum Bier irgendwo zu einer Konferenz zusammenzukommen, irgendwie gemeinsame Interessen auch zu verfolgen als ständig in Kleinkriegen gegen anderen Programmierern seine Lieblingsideen zu beschützen vor Veränderungen. Das sieht man in einigen Projekten, wo die Leute auch Bug Reports als persönlichen Angriff werten oder so Patches, die reinkommen, ist halt…
Das hört sich jetzt an, also wenn ich jetzt Nutzer am neuartigen Rundfunk-Empfangsgerät bin und diese Folge gehört habe, Chaos Radio, dann denke ich so, puh, das ist ja alles ganz schön kompliziert, ich lass die mal lieber machen. Also weil die Entwickler unter sich und dann haben die dann auch irgendwie sozialen Umgangsprobleme und das mit dem Geld weiß ich jetzt auch gar nicht mehr, ob ich jetzt spenden darf oder nicht. Ganz im Gegenteil.
Es gibt viele Communities, in denen das funktioniert und es gibt einige Ausgewählte, die dann immer platzen, weil es nicht funktioniert. Und die meisten, guck dir irgendwie Open Source-Projekte an, du benutzt selber Transmission, du benutzt so ein BitTorrent-Programm oder du benutzt ein Java-Programm, so Adium, was von vielen Freiwilligen mitgepflegt wird, die dann auch einfach einer setzt sich hin, macht eine Übersetzung ins Koreanische. So hat er einen Abend für Arbeit und dann ist seine Kontribution, wird reingenommen und er ist froh, dass er damit helfen konnte.
Und das funktioniert immer im Kleinen und wenn die Community toll ist und war nicht der Punkt, den ich machen wollte, sondern der Punkt, den ich machen wollte ist, dass ich als jemand, der überhaupt gar nichts mit diesem ganzen Ding zu tun hat, also nichts, ich bin wirklich nur Benutzer, was kann ich jetzt tun? Also ich hätte nach dieser Sendung den Eindruck, ich darf eigentlich jetzt nichts anfassen, weil egal was ich mache, es ist falsch.
Nee, genau andersrum. Geld ist immer gut, ohne jede Frage.
Da wird es nicht mehr an wen?
Na Free Software Foundation, wir haben gerade einige Sachen gelandet, die...
Da hat er gerade gesagt, er will nicht.
Manchmal gibt es aber nicht...
So war das vorhin von, das war missverständlich vielleicht, ich meinte das vorhin auf den ganz konkreten Fall GnuPG und jetzt nicht alle Open Source-Entwicklungen der Welt wird über die Free Software Foundation, sondern eher, dass die Free Software Foundation eine Patenschaft für ein Projekt übernehmen könnte, zum Beispiel. Aber genauso hilft es eben weiter, mal dir fällt ein Rechtschreibfehler auf der Homepage auf. Wir freuen uns, wenn wir einen Bug bekommen, oder wenn uns jemand darauf aufmerksam macht, da ist ein Rechtschreibfehler, das kann man im Englischen nicht so sagen, oder er übersetzt uns unsere Webseite in Zebräische, ich glaube, da kann man eher, man muss kein Programmierer sein, um in Open Source-Projekten zu helfen. Weil da gibt es an allen Ecken und Enden Arbeit.
Also es gibt auf jeden Fall, die meisten freien Software-Projekte freuen sich, wenn Leute mitmachen wollen. Es gibt auch welche, die sagen, will ich nicht, ist mir zu viel Arbeit, das möchte ich nicht. Da gibt es, wie gesagt, viele Möglichkeiten, man kann Sachen Korrektur lesen, man kann Sachen bewerten, übersetzen, all die Möglichkeiten. Aber wenn wir über die Finanzierung sprechen, ist für mich Geld wirklich ein entscheidender Faktor. Das ist ein entscheidender Faktor, der dazu mit beiträgt, dass Software, die für uns entwickelt wird, nicht in der Freizeit entwickelt wird, sondern dass die professionell in dem Hauptberuf mitentwickelt wird. Und manche Software, die wir brauchen, die ist so komplex, die können wir nicht abends mal kurz zwei Stunden entwickeln. Sondern das ist was, da müssen wir langfristig dran arbeiten. Und das ist für mich eine Sache, dass man, wenn man schaut, was für Software man verwendet, dass man dort auch einen Geldstrom zurückbringt. Also wenn ich auf meinem Computer, ich habe eine Mozilla Firefox, ich habe einen VLC, ich habe einen LibreOffice, ich habe einen Inkscape, ich habe einen Skribus oder sonst irgendwas, was auch immer ich da verwende. Warum bezahle ich für die Software kein Geld und gebe da nichts zurück, aber für die Software, die mir die Rechte wegnimmt, die mir vielleicht meine Daten klaut, ohne dass ich das weiß, weil ich die nicht überprüfen kann, weil das unfreie Software ist und niemand reingucken kann, was die eigentlich macht. Da steht ein Preis drauf, da bezahle ich was und das andere bekomme ich nicht hin. Und ich meine, das ist natürlich eine Sache, ist die Einstellung, dass manche Leute sagen, warum soll ich was bezahlen, was umsonst ist. Die andere Sache ist, wir sind einfach im Moment nicht in einem Stadium, dass das einfach ist, Geld zu geben. Ich glaube, das ist etwas, was wir bei den Apps gelernt haben. In einem App-Store ist es einfach, Geld zu geben. Da kann ich mal kurz einen Euro geben. Aber bei anderen Software ist es oft schwer oder die Projekte machen es noch schwer. Also früher, wenn man auf der LibreOffice-Seite gesucht hat, wie man spenden kann, das war echt schwer. Nachdem die das geändert haben, das war direkt auf der Download-Seite, kommt das noch drauf, haben die auf einmal sehr, sehr viel Geld eingenommen durch Spenden. Einfach, weil sie es prominent gezeigt haben. Und ich finde, das ist legitim für jedes freie Software-Projekt, für jeden freien Software-Programmierer, dass er die Möglichkeit, ihn finanziell zu unterstützen, auch prominent bewirbt. Es gibt natürlich auf der anderen Seite auch Leute, die sagen, ich will gar kein Geld, motiviert mich anders. Dann muss ich schauen, dass ich dem Projekt das anders gebe. Also wir hatten erst hier am 14.2. da machen wir jedes Jahr den I Love Free Software Day, wo wir sagen, motiviert Leute, sagt denen Dankeschön für das, was ihr von denen bekommt. Schreibt einen von den Projekten, danke für eure Arbeit. Heute nerfe ich nicht mit Bugreports, heute nerfe ich nicht mit neuen Feature-Requests, heute sage ich einfach mal Dankeschön, dass du diese Software gemacht hast.
Das wird wirklich gelesen?
Ja, das wird gelesen und die Rückmeldung, die wir von Entwicklern bekommen, ist auch, dass die sich darüber freuen.
Definitiv. Und das Einzige, was mir jetzt noch einfällt, ganz spontan ist, dass es möglicherweise gerade für die Leute, die jetzt eher kein Projekt im Rücken haben, sondern das eher privat machen, aber eher auch gerne mehr draus machen würden. Da habe ich jetzt letztens ein paar innovative Ideen gesehen. Es gibt so Initiativen wie Patreon, wo man sich Patronen für seine Arbeit, die einen monatlich mit einem Betrag x bestützen. Da gibt es also auch Softwareentwickler, die sowas machen. Aber unabhängig jetzt von einer konkreten Lösung, was möglicherweise auch etwas wie die FSFE machen könnte, fühle ich mich jetzt gerade spontan ein, vielleicht macht er das auch schon, ist ganz konkret Leuten auch Hinweise geben und den Tipps geben, wie sie mit solchen Spenden umgehen können, gerade auch in steuerlicher Hinsicht etc. pp. Weil ich glaube, das ist eine ganz starke Hürde, sobald ich irgendwie Geld einnehme, muss ich mit dem Finanzamt machen, wenn ich ansonsten angestellt bin, wo ich bisher überhaupt nichts mit zu tun hatte unter Umständen, maximal wenn ich mir Steuern zurückhören wollte. Plötzlich bin ich in einer ganz anderen Verantwortung, die ich eigentlich gar nicht haben will, weil ich will ja nur irgendwie zusehen, dass ich ein paar Stunden von meiner Arbeit vielleicht dann dem Softwareprojekt durch diese Spenden zukommen lassen möchte. Also dass man das da praktisch für die Leute, die eben eher kotversessen sind und den ganzen Infrastrukturkram nicht haben möchten, denen Hilfe zukommen lässt.
Also um das nochmal so zusammenzufassen, was teilweise passiert ist, dass Menschen Geld geben in der Entwicklung, der sagt, oh mein Gott, du machst mir gerade, das ist ein Problem für mich. Also ich muss jetzt überlegen, wie mache ich das mit der Steuer? Ich muss zum Steuerberater gehen, um zu gucken, was mache ich denn mit den 5000 Euro, die ich jetzt da gekriegt habe? Ich habe ja eigentlich einen Shop, ich bin Angestellter.
Also es gibt auf gar keinen Fall Geld für ein Open-Source-Projekt.
Nein, wenn jemand dir die Möglichkeit anbietet, dann hat er sich das meistens überlegt. Aber es gibt für die Fälle, müssen wir Lösungen finden, bei denen es möglich ist, dass man an einer Stelle Geld geben kann, damit diese Stelle wieder zum Beispiel den Server bezahlt, die Bandbreite bezahlt, zum Beispiel Reisekosten bezahlen kann für Entwickler, damit die sich treffen können. Solche Dinge, die für Entwickler, die noch nicht den Schritt gemacht haben, von Hobby-Programmierer zu Vollzeitangestellt.
Ganz wichtig, es gibt für einige Projekte, gibt es so Projektwunschlisten, wo sie sagen, hier die und die, die Hardware würde uns gerade ganz gut tun, da könnte man Treiber für entwickeln. Oder das und das, wie brauchen wir an Server, bitte besser kein Geld, aber Free Hosting irgendwo wäre total cool, das einfach mal drauf gucken, vielleicht hat man ja noch die Hardware im Keller liegen oder die extra Mega-Bitte noch frei auf seinem Server, dass man das anbieten kann.
Okay, also um das sozusagen kurz zusammenzufassen, möglichst einfach und hoffentlich trotzdem richtig. Wer auch immer Open Source Software benutzt, sich einfach mal Gedanken drum machen, wer da was dahinter steckt, also sich vielleicht mal die Crizes durchlesen, auf die Webseite gehen und gucken, was man den Leuten Gutes tun kann. Das sozusagen, also habe ich jetzt gerade den Eindruck, ist für den normalen User zumindest etwas Kleines, was er machen kann, was aber für den Entwickler schon viel Wert ist und die großen finanziellen Probleme, das ist eigentlich eher sowas, was in der Community und auch innerhalb der Firmen geklärt wird, also was eher tatsächlich ein politisches Anliegen auch ist, von der Größe her gesehen zumindest.
Also das ist auf jeden Fall auch eine Hausaufgabe, die wir jetzt mitbekommen haben, dass wir uns überlegen müssen, wie können wir langfristig Finanzierung für freie Software auf die Beine stellen.
Und auch die Projekte selber, wir hatten ganz oft das Problem, die Unis zum Beispiel wollten uns gerne Geld geben, die dürfen aber weder Geld spenden noch für Service und Support aufgeben. Die wollten gerne einen Preis zahlen, die wollten gerne uns 5000 Euro für eine Software exzipsen, dann zahlen die aber umsonst das, was dann wirklich ein jahrelanges Problem war, bis man irgendwann gesagt hat, gut, dann kleben wir trotzdem ein Preisschild drauf, ihr könnt euch natürlich auch umsonst runterladen.
Es kommt dazu Verwirrung. Wir müssen zum Schluss kommen, ich würde gerne von euch noch ganz am Ende wissen, was ist die nächste Software, die finanziell in Probleme kommen wird? Gibt es da schon einen Tipp? Oder ist jetzt erstmal alles geklärt? Betretenes Schweigen.
Das sind so viele, die wir jetzt da denken.
Na gut.
Aber wir hatten ganz kurz, wahrscheinlich sind es die Bibliotheken, die wir jetzt gar nicht im Fokus haben, weil sie nicht direkt sicherheitskritisch sind. So eine Lip-Set ist immer ein guter Kandidat, also so Zippen, Kleinigkeiten etc.
Lip-Tapel vielleicht.
Hausaufgabe an Danimo und Erdgeist, bitte für die Show notes noch heraus suchen, was das bedeutet, was ihr gerade gesagt habt, damit die Leute, die das jetzt noch verstehen wollen, das auch nachlesen können. Das war das Chaos-Radio 209, Finanzierung von der Open Source Software. Wir haben das Problem zumindest angerissen, wenn auch nicht ganz geklärt. Vielen Dank Erdgeist, Lasse, Matthias Kirschner von der FSFE und Danimo. Und ihr könnt diese Folge bestimmt auch bald runterladen unter chaosradio.ccc.de. Mein Name ist Marcus Richter, ich habe versucht, euch durch die Sendung zu führen und habe nur noch eine Nachricht für euch, lasst euch nicht überwachen und verschlüsselt immer schön eure Backups.